come on all right we should be live now
yeah I think it does start as soon as it
says you're live on the screen yeah I
thought it was a lag time but it's not
I'm here on my tablet and it hasn't gone
through so you have to back out of it
and now it's like you're gonna have the
you know turn the volume down you better
turn the vine yeah this again see every
single time he does that every single so
yeah you can't just sit on it wait you
gotta click out of it and then click
back into it
yeah I mended all that clicking in
clicking out and clicking in like a leg
over yes clicking in like a leg start to
show up let's get this give him a second
get everybody it's gonna be a good show
tonight folks it's gonna be a good show
tonight and yeah anything is here Hey
yeah they're all 10 of them just went
boom and it's still kind of lagging a
little bit or something about it it
always lags a little bit in the first
few minutes of the show I don't know why
that's kind of like why I always gonna
give it a few minutes I think it's just
because yeah the system trying to catch
up and everybody [ __ ] coming in on it
at the same time yeah it's just like oh
I can't take it Tom needs to dress up as
the saxophone man from Lost Boys this
Halloween oh yeah you should that's just
what a g-string and a saxophone know he
had pants on right yeah pants on I think
they get pants with like like leather
chaps over them am I remembering that
wrong saxophone man just you don't have
a shirt on saxophone man is just a
[ __ ] epic [ __ ] saxophone
bodybuilder man [ __ ] with long
[ __ ] hair you just need like long
rocker hair and the saxophone and then
you could have pants and then you could
just have like I don't know you could
have something I just said welcome to
Santa Carla that's something Sophie saw
him live just a couple months ago hey
more claims of fame that
got so you know a nosy that and lots of
baby oil that's what I was gonna say
like in some bronzer yeah anabolics are
a hell of a drug but if you do it right
those nudes don't age ya see what's
going on either that or he's got like a
Dorian Gray painting like a Vinokur some
[ __ ] like that I mean I haven't seen him
lately so I don't know if he looks the
same or not but you can play though and
evidently the [ __ ] crowd was going
wild
well yeah cuz he looks a big camp yeah
he does but he puts on a [ __ ]
fantastic show everybody loved if he
came out with no shirt on yeah evidently
worse you might talk money so he said
he'd look exactly like he did in the
eighties just muscles [ __ ] long curly
hair and a saxophone looked exactly like
that he sleeps in a Tupperware container
Katya she thought actually she thought
he'd made it maybe bigger than he was
yeah yeah of course of course you can
the roids
you can't not hemorrhoids no yeah right
you can't build a body like to that
proportions without Thank You Nico like
we're only three minutes in we're in
three minutes in we're letting this [ __ ]
[ __ ] warm up we're letting everybody
show up so that's kind of like the
pre-show I'm gonna pregame here in a
minute you see me make my drink yeah you
haven't usually he runs off to the
kitchen and make the Japanese like today
we're gonna do it live right here do it
right here once you start rolling I
already got one but what saxophone man
you cannot build a physique like that
without anabolics it's just a given you
can't do it yes yeah I've seen natural
bodybuilders after [ __ ] 20 or 30
years that you can't do it no but you
know you'd have to have [ __ ]
fantastic genetics and one-in-a-million
genetics to do that you know it's not
possible
yeah no not possible you can just tell
well I mean that's that dudes lively
yeah yeah so you can't blame them you
just can't get that freaky looking
weight without it that's just too much
upper body and it's just too damn lean
yeah I mean yeah you can't gain that
much mass and have it that
without anabolics well yeah because you
have to eat a lot of calories normally
would make you fat an anabolic steroids
will just burn every ounce of fat off
you yeah
if you doing them right you just become
you look like one of them Chinese cattle
you see that picture there damn Chinese
cow where they did something to it it
was some kind of a growth hormone they
gave it it just looks like a [ __ ]
pile of [ __ ] muscle I don't think it
looks good actually I think it's nothing
it's just too freaky who the cow are the
people the people well yeah it looks too
freaky well once you get past a certain
point like I said it's it's just kind of
like you know everything in moderation
it should sound like a little bit of
plastic surgery is good but then after a
certain point if you're starting to look
like your favorite staple to the back of
your skull and like you know I mean
every dudes gonna do it he wants to do
if that's how if he wants to look like a
[ __ ] anatomy chart that's that's
that's you know hit his body he can do
it you know if he wants to women have
been [ __ ] with their hormones forever
just for birth control
yeah and he's that's not fun if these
dudes one knows not to make a woman
crazy and make a man crazy to take that
kind of anabolic Stu you need all kinds
of mood stabilizers but if you want to
do it that's your right I mean if you
want to be one of these Barbie fake
Barbie girls that weighs 100 pounds and
[ __ ] got 40 pounds of fake fake tit
piled on top of that built a cliff that
is she can do that that's her right you
know I mean that's a fetish and that's
why that's the way I see what you'd call
straight and yes Amen it's after a
certain point it's like gets fetishist
it's a fetishistic
those guys all have manorexia you know I
mean they they have to look that bit big
and they never really seem to be quite
satisfied with the way they look you
know I mean I'm not like that I like to
be [ __ ] to have a muscular physique
and be a good shape and [ __ ] look
manly that's it but that's not that
doesn't that's not that hard right
that's not that hard you know when you
start getting older it is you know and I
think a lot of those guys so I can start
[ __ ] around a little bit of anabolics
I mean it's just you're trying to
compensate for [ __ ] biological
[ __ ] you know problems that have them
you trying to compensate from biological
decline yeah I mean y'all you look at
Stallone
70 something years old he looks pretty
good he looks a lot better than your
average 70 year old I've seen him in a
gym [ __ ] when he was in his 60s just
so I could tearing [ __ ] up you know if I
can stronger than most teenagers you
know yeah stronger than most teenagers
so you might it might cost you a few
years at the end of your life but you
get you know you're trading in life span
for life quality it's the last one last
ones anyway and you wouldn't know if you
were gonna like you just die when you
die you don't know if you would have
lived longer than the dudes that die
from that [ __ ] they still die pretty old
most of them but they're dying from
complications of [ __ ] steroid abuse
yeah abused the [ __ ] out of it when they
were really [ __ ] young that's not
really what what Stallone did Stallone
really didn't mess with it that much you
know he did a little bit but not a whole
lot and then he started using it later
on in life but so did so did Jack
LaLanne and if you look at Jack LaLanne
Jack LaLanne lived to be in his 90s he
did yeah and that do this [ __ ] in
great condition actually no was he a
hundred I think he was 96
but his physicality was he was stronger
than me was he the one that did the did
he do all the juicing stuff later like
the all you know with all the fruit
juice per guest right yeah he became an
infomercial guy that's what I thought I
thought that was but when he was in his
50s he was slim swimming Inglis channel
was dim boat towing a boat and his teeth
by a rope and all he was doing that his
fifties he was [ __ ] amazing he's like
[ __ ] you twenty-year-old yeah do Nana's
fifties he lived a long long time and he
was strong and his whole life but he
didn't abuse steroids he was young yes a
fitness expert all throughout his youth
and when he started to decline he said
[ __ ] I'm gonna take some O's
anabolics oh yeah once you get to a
certain age it's like pretty much they
know it's just people that start really
young and it's just kind of like
anything else like anything else you
know if you start something rolling
young and just do it for years and years
this is a known science and humans have
been experimenting with it for [ __ ]
decades going back to the 50s and 60s
and doctors doctors don't know anything
about it they you know most doctors are
just glorified drug dealers really they
just know what they're told they see it
being abused you know in gyms and in
sports medicine so they assume that it
kills you now if you use it right it's
life extension like I said when you're
old yeah it's like don't you write it
when you're 18 and then do it for years
and years right you don't want to overdo
it but there's all kinds of [ __ ]
black market and gray market [ __ ] going
on if you got the money and the and the
knowledge they got dudes doing all kinds
of weird [ __ ] that's extending their
lives
yeah means rich people you know some
have been on their fourth [ __ ] heart
transplant run around with them damn
Chinese hearts you know like the [ __ ]
the Rockefellers Salkind full of turkey
necks full of turkey necks blood
transfusion the [ __ ] 15 year old
chill there's a callback
yeah do all kinds of [ __ ] whacked-out
[ __ ] the shooter by saying Maria says
have you guys discovered the flavored
schnapps 99 I think I bought you some
grape 99 when I still have that peanut
butter vodka be really related like
peanut butter and jelly cocktail yeah
you get grape 99 with peanut butter
flavored vodka
it used to be van Gogh but I don't know
if they make that anymore no yeah I
think they're out of business now but
you can get pinnacle yeah Pinnacle's got
that right you mix that together about
even about one part in one part and then
two parts [ __ ] coca-cola and around a
rim to go to salt rimmed glass manage
it's good it really is yeah really good
where are the drinks - right here yeah
like mine is - thank you again
yes mine is a screwdriver yeah what do
you put grenadine and it's here right so
yeah yeah that's called a and he's gonna
pour his vodka it's called a vodka
sunset yeah rock star energy drink yeah
we had a good public yeah energy drinks
and I got there I said I've got a [ __ ]
already loaded up in that [ __ ] vodka on
the rocks
drinking vodka today yeah I was thank
you Matt normally thank you very much
Matt normally I would be drinking silver
tequila but I'm out of silver all I have
is some really nice Reposado
we were out today you said that you
didn't want
I might mix Reposado and then in the
next drink but I just wanted to start
off kind of mellow you know because
silver silver tequila is actually kind
of like a Mexican vodka it's a lot like
vodka I mean I am some apple whiskey too
and I do mix that with apple juice
partly because that's really good I know
people are like grossed out by Jim Beam
apple but I really like it well then
that might be is that Jim Beam or is it
what's the other one
no no Jim Beam I think for some reason I
really like the outside the Maples maybe
that's any energy drink mixes with vodka
though everything mixes with vodka
that's what's so nice about it that's
why I always get vodka because listen
that's why I always get vodka because it
goes with everything so whatever juice
we have laying around the house or
whatever so we don't usually have sodas
imagine everybody's wondering what the
show is gonna be I was getting sick of
the [ __ ] murder stuff you don't man
yeah and he basically said cuz like I
said before I try to like you know go
from like true crime one week's apparent
old so but I'm running out of like
paranormal stuff or weird stuff you know
that people requested so it's like in
most of the stuff people request is true
crime but he was just kind of like you
know I'm sick of doing trigger I'm so I
said you know what I'm gonna do like a
kind of grab bag of like weird auditory
phenomena because that's been requested
like a long time and I've had it like on
the list for a long time I'm talking
about the weird humming sound so we're
gonna talk about the bloop that happened
underneath the ocean we talking about
all kinds of [ __ ] the mood is noises
yeah Havana syndrome there's like some
stuff which might be audio they're not
really entirely sure what's causing that
also I wanted to talk about the 52 Hertz
wail otherwise known as the loneliest
whale in the world and some other whale
related things too but I just thought
this would kind of be a fun like
grab-bag kind of show of like a bunch of
weird auditory phenom
what are you doing move this thing out
of the way me man's blocking me I gotta
be in the camera song you gonna hold
back how are you away from the internet
let that [ __ ] go on cuz I am Paul muah
deep the his s cataract the more deep DJ
maniacs s man wait for the new dude
I know I can't wait says manorexia was a
fetus side-project was it really I
didn't know that
what's that fetus that's like that was a
band mmm they I knew they had a bunch of
side projects but I didn't I wasn't
aware of the one that was called panorex
yeah well sometimes I'm anorexia it's a
reality and this pro bodybuilders they
all come they all have it if you don't
have manorexia you're not gonna be a pro
body it's access time you're such a
narcissist superpower he also as she
said what's that car terrain stuff you
told me about coke artery Carter II
needed man you're trying to get me to
talk about [ __ ] great more you okay I
can't even tell you a supplier not in
public but there it's out there it's not
an illegal drug it's just it's just a
drug that has not been approved for
human use it was used in the Olympics I
think it was in 2000 the 2010 on the
picture of 2009 on this what year was
2008 at Olympics yeah they're usually
four years yeah 2008 Olympics I thought
it was made by GlaxoSmithKline it was
supposed to be they were gonna market it
as exercise in a bob to where you could
take it orally you can drink it look at
and um it would fool your body into
burning fast stores instead of the
[ __ ] carbohydrates in your
bloodstream and you would lose weight
that's what it was for but they found
out I didn't really work so easily you
know I mean they weren't it was
something they were gonna sell to just
women working in offices here take this
and you need all the doughnuts you want
all doughnuts you want
yeah - you wouldn't have [ __ ] worked
because they just would have taken a
whole bunch of it needs a bunch of
donuts and possibly could have caused
cancer all right but what it did do they
found out that he gave you a damn near
really good endurance you don't really
get tired
had I known about it in the service it
didn't exist back then but that's
something I would have taken in the army
you just don't get tired
the tired again you get the more energy
you get but they found out that guys in
the Olympics were taking it so they
banned it from the Olympics and
GlaxoSmithKline decided to pull it from
the market or at least get rid of it get
rid of their research because they
didn't want anybody else to copy what
they did is they gave a bunch of
overdoses to a bunch of test rats and
gave them all cancer and it was a kind
of rat that got cancer easily anyway and
they were given a thing about it for
those easy cancer yeah there's a certain
breed of rat that's very sensitive to
cancer that they use for a cancer test
and they were given those rats kind of
like the dosages that would it be
equivalent to like drinking it down half
a kid a half a cup [ __ ] coca-cola cat
of it a day all right
and over that over a few years the
[ __ ] rats got [ __ ] cancer those
rats didn't live long anyway you know I
mean they're a rat that might only only
live a couple years you know and because
of because all the cats all the rats got
cancer nobody wanted to deal with it
anymore and they closed it down but no
human has ever gotten any cancer from it
we know people have been taking it and
doctors have been taking it too you know
doctors take a lot of drugs some people
don't know this but doctor if doctors
are [ __ ] drug addicts a lot of them
well it's just easy to get him cuz it's
like oh I think I'll have some of this
and I'll thank you prescriptions for no
weird uses for all these drugs and they
take them themselves they're not
necessarily good higher there's like
well I can kill this one keep me working
this one actually gives me more mental
focus you know may have [ __ ] out there
like that weird mind-altering type
[ __ ] drugs and now you're just a
drink I mean yeah
I can't keep track of all those
different drugs it's like well I need
this one to do this and then I knew is
one of the counteract the effects of
that one and I need this like that's too
much work but car terrine I just I'll
just get drunk and sleep you come take
about a three-month cycle of car terrine
and if you're walking and doing some
aerobics it'll really help out [ __ ]
weightlifting because you just don't get
tired you can do a lot more reps than
you normally would have been a car
Torino [ __ ] build a lot of it'll you
know burn your fat stores if you're if
you're exercising it doesn't work as
advertised though they were wanted to
advertise that you could sit on your ass
and lose and eat whatever you want us
now which I don't even know there's not
a drug know exists that will do that and
even if there was a drug that existed
they do that I'm sure it would be very
very harmful and yeah your organs you
can lose weight but you gotta lose
weight the old-fashioned way you can
take car terrine and you can [ __ ] run
and [ __ ] do all kinds of work and
you'll lose weight a lot faster that way
but it won't work if you're just sitting
on your ass yeah which like I said to me
that just negates the whole purpose of
having a drug in the first place because
if you have a drug like that you want it
to be so you can sit around your ass and
eat doughnuts and just take a good like
you know won't lose weight if you have
to exercise anyway you might as well not
even take the no no because what happens
is if you're exercising you'll burn a
certain amount of fat all right yeah
it's a little bit but if your axe if
you're taking car to read and do that
same amount of work no you'll burn about
a lot three times yeah okay but you know
that's good yeah it's very I'm just
saying that most people that would want
to take something those advertises
exercise right it's just kind of the
same principle as I bought the diet ice
cream or the diet okay so they just eat
something more of it there's no calories
of the diet XO SmithKline are already
foresaw what the problems would be it
it'd be a bunch of lawsuits you have a
bunch of over weight overeating chicks
in the [ __ ] office eating a [ __ ] ton
of donuts how probably games as well and
then they'd be and then they'd be for
exactly but you know they were going to
market it to women well they thought
they were going to so they'd be stuff in
their face in the office because and
then they'd say well because I'm
stuffing my face but I got this
they tell me to take ten milligrams but
I'm gonna take 70 milligrams instead
yeah cuz that'll make all that because
then it'll burn it off even faster I can
all coughing because there's always
gonna be a certain amount of people that
will do that
yeah well I'm overeating so I'm just
gonna take a lot of this ya know for
some reason I'm not losing weight but I
sure did get cancer so man I sure did so
that one's on the underground there's
another shirt Wow I searched yeah so
that's one of them it's in the
underground it's in the grey market you
can get it all right but I'm not gonna
advertise any any sources it's out do
you remember back in they all go for a
Chinese source go for an American source
yeah because there's some sort of like
made in this third part is illegal like
I said they're not illegal it's just it
on YouTube might pull a video if I give
that kind of advice they don't like the
internet doesn't like this [ __ ]
in fact visa won't let you buy you'd
have to go through cryptocurrency to buy
it yeah yeah I'm like thundering it's so
I thought I heard the lightning alarm
which I don't know if you guys have that
where we are but wait because there's
like a long walking trail like around
the county that's like right behind our
house so whenever like lightning gets
seen wherever the sensor is it sends
like this really big alarm like hey you
get off the path you're gonna get struck
by lightning but yeah so sometimes you
can hear in the background no it's like
for some reason that exercise and a
bottle thing reminded me of remember I
don't even remember how long ago this
was but you remember when they were
making potato chips with that that fat
substitute olestra and remember how it
was in like that would they put into
like potato chips or Pringles or
something like that and everyone was
laughing because one of the side effects
was anal leakage it was fat substitute
some person tastes like fat and it
didn't like have any calories but it
would like make you poke yourself
mangoes mango badger said he worked for
GlaxoSmithKline and he says I'm
describing the employees perfectly there
make a drug just they do like I said
like experiment with [ __ ] yeah and then
nico nico sanchez is saying go for
colombian I think he's saying just coke
coke I make you skinny as a [ __ ]
but it also might make you suck dick for
a lil
so you better got a watch coat well some
guys I've had more that coat how do I
get more other come over here it happens
to some guys I don't [ __ ] with that [ __ ]
well you know like I guess it's like
anything else some people can do it and
leave it alone and some people can't
yeah I can walk away from it I've tried
it a long time ago they've got only on a
couple occasions but I can see how you
could fall down a [ __ ] to fall down
into a [ __ ] hole with that [ __ ] yeah
it runs out and you go I sure would like
some more of that my advice is when you
say I sure would like some more then go
out go back up to the bar and just drink
yourself into a [ __ ] you don't want
any more of it it'll be over when you
[Laughter]
open the power doesn't go out because I
don't think it's like this damn storm
out yeah it's like looks like that's the
that's a perfect environment for this
show though cuz it's gonna be storming
and weird and we're gonna look into some
of these weird [ __ ] weird [ __ ]
auditory auditory thousand things
olestra wear brown pants that should
have been there that should have been
their slogan like they're alright so um
let me do I had a couple of shadows - I
totally we've gone on like half an hour
livestream and everybody coming in we
got 30 of them in there now so we can
start the show we gonna yeah um yeah so
one of the first things I wanted to do
was we had I mentioned this on one of
our live streams was like a matinee or a
sidetracks or something like that I
think it was on Wednesday but like I
said I was like oh my goodness yeah I
know holy [ __ ]
yeah cuz like I said the windows right
there um but I always like to mention
them on the main show as well so I
wanted to thank our newest patron whose
name is Terry so thank you very much
Terry and welcome she said she likes to
watch the show with her daughter
so that's pretty cool right there also
where I'm not gonna clean up my language
I'm sorry water I don't know
daughter might be grown yeah she might
be grown that's what I mean it's like I
really am no one should be letting their
children watch some crazy [ __ ] or the or
the subject matter I don't know it's
like it's all fun and games I don't know
if I'd have a problem at all what kids
watch it but I probably would watch some
[ __ ] like this how the kid but you know
I was kind of a fun job also in case you
guys didn't notice and I we talked about
a little bit on the live stream the
other day but this fantastic Frank
Frazetta on campus back here oh yeah
yeah I got talking about this this is
this was Tom's birthday present it's my
birthday present from Sophie yeah good
good friend of ours he's been over here
and a big fan of the show and one time I
was showing Sophie photos some Frank
Frazetta pegs online showing it to her
she's just [ __ ] love you see we were
talking about Cody at the time and just
talking about the primal essence of a
[ __ ] of the beauty of a primal
essence of a rosetta painting everything
is about [ __ ] maximum [ __ ]
masculinity maximum femininity [ __ ]
it's just like the maximum of a human
essence it's all about [ __ ] some [ __ ]
up
or trying to keep some [ __ ] from getting
[ __ ] up it's everything is about
struggle so I'm Nietzschean very much
like some Mota Nietzsche and for she
gave me this for Zed on canvas man it's
a canvas it's not a poster it's nice
it's really nice it is I want to thank
you it looks like super cool back there
yeah and it's called the Barbarian yeah
but it's definitely Conan you know he
did all the covers for the Conan
although Elvis Rivera says is that
presentist interpretation of brass Dan
yes exactly I want you how you brought
that [ __ ] up it's um but working
mortgage [ __ ] already happened he
avoided it somebody else someone else
it's actually this is like this is like
the essence of Tom Ross right here and
then that's Jenny right there underneath
the feet listen this is nuts
it's us yet another dimension
I wish I was that big look at that
[ __ ] look at that [ __ ] he's bigger
than Arnold well yeah I mean I don't you
know I don't know like I'm sure he used
like human models and stuff no he didn't
he just did they just did him on yeah
well I get it actually you draw somebody
cuz I used to draw like a long time if
you look at his figures they're almost
cartoonish you know no human could
really be those proportions half the
time the women are just amazing
proportions he we had similar taste in
women we like full-figured kind of woman
you mean tits and ass booties and oh
yeah yeah yeah shape like shape on a
wagon big ol thoughts yeah I could
probably write Marsh man's neck it's I
just know it taste some that reminded me
because you said something about another
dimension speaking of other dimensions I
told people that I was gonna do a review
of like all three seasons of dark I'm
almost to the end of season three only
two episodes left so I will probably do
it on a live stream on Monday we're
gonna do a live stream tomorrow as well
but it'll probably be a review of
actually a quite good news shutter
original horror movie that we saw last
night called the beach house which is
kind of like an environmental horror so
we'll probably do a review of that
tomorrow and I'll probably cuz I like I
said I only have two Episode the dark
left and so we'll probably talk about
that on yes Monday they've mentioned
another mention another show yes he's
been eating loads of bull testicles
that's my kid it's like a prehistoric
roids yeah and you sit around he tested
those we need to do a show about that
dude a camera what his name is I read a
book about him a couple years ago but
like that guy that started like the
whole radio advertising thing and like
the guy that would put like go testicles
in dude skirts yeah oh yeah but we're
talking about that guy we need to get
into that weird [ __ ] world medicine
[ __ ] I love that kind of [ __ ] and like I
read I read a book about that guy
and it's like there there's like all
these like weird little byways of like
American history of the European history
[ __ ] like that it doesn't really get
talked about a lot and it's like every
time I use because I used to go to
very like every two or three weeks and
check out like this huge like stack of
books and that was one thing that always
attracted me is like the history of
something that you never think about the
history of is it's always like way more
interesting like one of the most
fascinating books I ever read was called
and I remember the title is no no it's
called the perfect read and it was
basically about that die that they made
from like those crushed bug Cara paces
you know what I mean um in like the
whole trade in that die like going back
like centuries and centuries that book
was [ __ ] fascinating yeah it was
fascinating yeah and it's like so I love
all that kind of stuff so that's how I
ended up reading that book about the go
testicle dude who like I said was also a
big pioneer in radio advertising he was
kind of he had his own like he made so
much money with the goat testicle stick
that he like bought his own radio
station and he was like the first person
to use radio is like an advertising kind
of thing so he's like a fascinating kind
of guy DJ maniac said that legally for
said it could not use the name Conan
that's what I figured yeah exactly it
was a rapper he just called a barbarian
but but for seven did most of the
graphic designs and all the design but
involved with Conan for the later
probably not only they have the
re-releases of the books that I did the
covers also the look of Conan for the
movie which Conan the Barbarian the
first one for from the DiLaurentis yeah
Conan with [ __ ] with man I love that
movie and it just I don't know a lot of
you guys a private maybe like me or I
don't know I think you guys are probably
like me if you [ __ ] subscribe to the
show
I've always basically been a hero
worship since it's a boy you know
growing up looking at a heavy metal
magazine you know and these movies and
coming up in a military academy and
going into into the into the army itself
I've just even though I had kind of like
a Christian upbringing really I was
pagan I was [ __ ] a hero worshiper
that's that's really what I like was it
to start probably starting off with
heavy metal magazine and and Star Wars
yeah that's really where it started and
Star Wars is very religious in its cut
and it's
it is scheria it's so and it's very much
something out of luck in beach in scope
an hour which Stethem comes right into
[ __ ] conan same-same mythology you
know I'm into that mythological [ __ ]
yeah which I'm [ __ ] kind of like
today's society man is really lacking
that relaxed lacking this kind of [ __ ]
and I look at some of these young guys
come up today and I just can't imagine
the world they're come that I can't
imagine the world that they live in you
know I mean just I can't imagine being
like that because they're missing out on
all that good stuff well I don't know
it's like I think they every every
generation kind of constructs their own
mythology in a way it's like even though
it's maybe not one that you would
recognize as a mythology because it
hasn't been around for a long time but
the male mythology of today is in a sad
state I was gonna say that that's a sad
state these boys aren't even going
through puberty properly I'm just
starting to get wound up it's very early
our engine that's good yeah be with you
Maria said she read that ghost go
testicle guidebook to if that was really
good wasn't it I have to like remember
it's it's in my I have a oh thank you
again Nico I have um on Goodreads I have
like a whole bookshelf of like all the
books I've ever read I try to keep track
and [ __ ] on there just so I don't forget
whenever I say some [ __ ] male
chauvinist [ __ ] Nico sent me some money
I don't want to call it male chauvinism
that's not me I'm sure that's just I'm a
masculinist you know I'm Provost I like
I like I like the male virtues but I
appreciate the female virtue like a
manly [ __ ] I like Manick Ballack
womanly [ __ ] - I like hyper sexuality
[Music]
probably from coming up coming up in
Brazil maybe maybe toxoplasmosis I don't
know what it is it's something you read
original Howard's Tales Conan is nothing
yeah he
nothing like the boat yeah yeah he's
nothing like Arnold Schwarzenegger Conan
was like a general he was a warrior
general he was real [ __ ] intelligent
and everything kind of crafty yet he was
he was he was a good mixture of brains
and brawn you know he was well-rounded
which is good that's kind of like what
you want but you know Conan the movies
you know the the the De Laurentiis
movies I think we're gonna go in that
direction
it's just that they lost a million and
and John Milius he wrote the first one
but he didn't write the second one in
the third one and man they really went
downhill they started to marketing more
towards that one was really kind of
really bad well it was bad man I haven't
forgotten like we watched it again
because you have all of them and it's
like I watched it again I was like the
writing had declined a lot yeah it was
just like coding like they were on
cutting it was up here and ii was just
kinda like Milius was originally gonna
have I mean Grace Jones is rad but you
know it was almost good it's just that
it didn't have Milius and it didn't have
the right writing all right and this
affects her worship they were shitty and
it was gonna have a stir there's gonna
be a trilogy where Conan was gonna have
a developmental arc which would have
been awesome it was supposed to be the
prehistoric Star Wars that's what Milius
said it was gonna be so did James Earl
Jones general Jones own James Earl Jones
said that this was prehistoric Star Wars
and he was prehistoric Darth Vader
basically when his plan Tulsa also doom
I would say probably Arnold's version or
at Arnold's version of Conan was
probably closer to crawl a conqueror but
you know it's just my take on now I will
say that I haven't read I've read some
Robert E Howard because I have a thing
about because I'm probably partially for
my witching hour show too but I go back
and read like old issues of weird tales
you know like we're HP Lovecraft used to
like from the 20s and stuff and Robert E
Howard used to publish [ __ ] tons of
plague stories in there and some of them
really good they're usually more fantasy
based which like I said I'm more of a
horror person but you know that he's a
good writer I have to say but I said one
of these days I'll get around a
redesigned the company and books I
probably [ __ ] but Michael Syst Tom's not
old [ __ ] Amina but he says I was born in
73 I was born in [ __ ] is 69 yes born in
69
I'm pretty old I'm coming up on 51 51
yeah yeah I'm 51 he'd you just turned 51
yeah my first actual yeah just turned 51
I don't feel it though I only feel it
when I'm around real young people
because they grew up in a world that
just [ __ ] just
pales in comparison growing up in the
70s in the 80s was [ __ ] the best
[ __ ] cuz we grew up feral basically
well there's some things I liked I liked
coming to my majority at such like um
you know a transitional time period like
I really liked that you know my early
childhood and teenage years
correspondent with like punk and
post-punk and like the VHS boom and like
all this kind of like new cultural [ __ ]
that was happening I really really like
that that happened like I said I
wouldn't go back to the 80s because
there's a lot of stuff that sucked about
them too but I really liked that that
was kind of like the trajectory of my
yoshiya our early childhood development
in the 70s when we were little kids we
spent most of time outside the house
yeah our parents were like yes so you
know I want to be in here playing bridge
and smoking I was either out in the
woods I'm Mississippi arbors in the damn
[ __ ] storm drains in [ __ ]
California you know it's the [ __ ]
flood control centers flood control
that's where you know in Terminator 2
you know the [ __ ] terminator was
ramping down there you know and [ __ ]
you know that that's that's where I grew
up looking for the giant ass from them
from a film that [ __ ] we used to just
like hang out in the woods and because
it was woods by our house and we just
like would be out there collecting
tadpoles doing fire blowing firecrackers
up
yeah and launching GI Joes into space
I'd be like I'd be like six I was like
six seven eight nine and my only
you know my only [ __ ] restriction was
I had to be in before was dark yeah it's
like as always pretty much I think like
70s and 80s kid
to grow up then there were just like
well as soon as the streetlights come on
you know come back again that's right
streetlights and like you know cuz it's
dinnertime right we used to [ __ ] boy
we used to just wait until the street
ice came out okay we gotta go in five
yeah
no more blowing yeah I was dressed up
like Evel Knievel and [ __ ] I thought it
was like with you Frampton Comes Alive
[Laughter]
Steve Miller Band fly like an eagle so
do you want to like now that we're like
38 minutes in do I start talking about
we got it I'm still oh well it's well
it's I think of myself as old but not
really it's not the same as it was um
back at you know when we were growing up
like our parents seemed very old because
there was such a there was such a wide
gap in like the values and the culture
and everything like that yeah I don't
really think I mean I think that's
garishly disappeared yeah I mean you
know there's still a gap obviously
between like really [ __ ] old people
like boobs and stuff right but I mean
even we still feel that like you know
boomers having different values to us
but I mean between people because I've
like talked to people to Club and [ __ ]
like that that are you know young enough
to be my kid and they are into like
they've seen all the same movies they've
seen all they they're into the same
music and [ __ ] like that so you can talk
to them like you can talk to someone
your age and it's not yeah and you know
there are some gaps here and there just
because there's a lot to catch up on but
I never found it like frustrating we
were kind of in in the goth industrial
scene you know which maybe it's a
special case right so x-gen people and
millennial people and Zoomers in that
scene there's not a big difference
not really outside the scene I mean I
know a jock when I see one even they're
real they kind of blow whatever here
there that's like yeah we had those
we don't know what they call back in my
day they call them jocks now they
probably call them something more like
Bros or some [ __ ] like I do think bro is
thing grows but they call but we used to
call him Jax even though they did say
even if they didn't [ __ ] even if they
weren't into sports most [ __ ] jocks
weren't in a sports they were bullying
was just like a type it was a
personality
they were [ __ ] betas really they were
[ __ ] betas they wished they were
playing sports and they were [ __ ]
running around acting like [ __ ] and
[ __ ] but can when we when we were in
high school we actually [ __ ] hung out
with some of the [ __ ] hockey players
and some of the football players and
they were cool a real jock was cool it
was a fake jock that way yeah it was
just the wrong set although I can say I
wanna be where I went to school some of
the real jocks were dicks to that time
you know I was hanging out with Steve
and we were in the theater we were
[ __ ] [ __ ] around with [ __ ]
metal music and bands and we had cool
girls around us all time we all had weed
that jocks needed [ __ ] yeah and and you
know they were like there's no get sweet
that cut stuff and and you know
sometimes they become the same parties
as I stand they kind of respected us
that we had our own thing and they had
their thing
it was the baddest that was [ __ ] well
they're always the people that are
trying to be some drier than wannabes
yeah that's I think that's mainly the
issue more than anything else like more
than a personality Atty for anything
because even though most of the people I
hung out with in high school were you
know weird it was I really liked geeks
and dorks boxes every thanks but we did
have a few like quote-unquote Normie
people that hung out with us so you know
there was nothing with that and honestly
most of the most of our friend group was
more because we were all in gifted you
know what I mean so we were like all the
gifted kids yeah so some of them are
normal and some of them were we're don't
know what she meant
I gotta show them something what do you
got I got a picture of a high school
punk rock girlfriend on my show so can't
believe her 40 but this generation I
might need another drink in a minute all
right there you go
1987 there you go that's the way that's
the way they looked I had in high school
which was 88 and 1998
I'm old but uh I had I didn't have my
hair was in black it was still my
natural color which is like kind of
orange red but I had I had half of it
like shaved off like so this half was
all shaved off and it was like long in
the back and then like it was all spiky
in the front and I had I bought at the
[ __ ] army surplus store I had like my
you know combat boots that's kind of
like a given but I found this for like
really cool trench coat I think it was
at [ __ ] Goodwill and it was like this
pea-green trench coat and inside was
like orange and pea green like paisley
pattern I love that it was $3 and I
loved that [ __ ] trench coat
I wore that trench coat with my alien
sex fiend shirt I might [ __ ] half
shaved head and my [ __ ] boots I
couldn't afford Doc Martens cuz they
were too expensive you had to order them
from the UK back then but I had like the
kind of the cheap army boots that you
got at the army surplus store that I got
in Daytona Beach me and my brother have
messiness and money yes okay
yeah I said but yeah thank you thank you
very much man but yeah so that's kind of
like my won't have shaved out of my
[ __ ] trench coat I wear that [ __ ] all
the time
y'all gonna be passed out by the end no
I would be alright probably work we're
seasoned drinkers and we're gonna we can
take a break and stuff too well someone
suggested I can't say already warned
hambrick well no Sandra no they said an
hour and a half in we should do like a
five-minute like pee break we can do it
right what we're gonna we do that I mean
we have to do that anyway it's like and
like I said if you miss something you
can just come back and watch it later
it's not yeah we'll leave it's not like
it's gone forever
we'll leave it running will go out week
usually take turns taking breaks and
stuff yeah because and like I said I
might take a break in a minute cause I'm
always I'm gonna make you another drink
you should yeah we're give it to me I'll
make another drink now I'll tell you
what you take a break we okay well we
can't we can't leave it like empty I
wonder what ever happened uh oh yeah you
can go okay you can go I don't I don't
actually have to go to the bathroom or
anything like that I'm fine
jenny was awesome in high school I bet I
don't know like I I kind of feel like I
was I liked high school junior high I
hated because I was kind of like the
NuWave kid in
you're high and also I was poor and the
junior high in the high school I went to
were kind of like more in the kind of
Richie kind of neighborhood because
here's something that a lot of people
did back in the day was that if you were
kind of poor like sometimes you would
give like a relative's address you could
go to like a better school you know what
I mean
so we kind of did that so we gave them
like my aunt uncle's address so that I
could go to a better school so I didn't
have to go to the one that was you know
near where where we actually lived
because it was like a terrible junior
high it was like you know like a really
bad like lowly low rated one so I ended
up going to school with a bunch of like
much wealthier kids like upper-middle
class kind of kids and they did not take
too kindly to poor children that had
like I said shoes from Kmart because
they recognized that [ __ ] right away
like you could try to get away with it
but they they knew what that [ __ ] was
and if it was just like pretty in pink
like she had [ __ ] from [ __ ] from the
from the thrift store and everybody made
fun of her it was kind of like that so I
did have like friends and stuff but
junior high was like super shitty and
also because you know being oh thank you
being like in the gifted classes and
being chill so you know everybody kind
of made fun of you for that too but high
school was a lot better because even
though you still got picked on by the
rich kids there was a lot of other like
you know little punk rock kids and there
was more of a scene in that way so I did
it like have some other people to hang
out with people are like band geeks and
chorus geeks and drama geeks and uh I
guess you were kind of a drama geek in
high school weren't you
no but you're a little bit of a drama
geek in high school no I'm a geek but
you were in drama yeah I used to get a
lot of leads me and Steve [ __ ] ran
that [ __ ] as far as male leads yeah you
were in all kind of like musicals and
stuff I was gonna be an actor
yeah but then like I thought about as I
[ __ ] no but like the girls were dating
me all became actresses yeah you know if
I can marry LAN yeah [ __ ] you she's on
24 yes she's on 24 yeah and then that
other girl that I hung out with the
Mississippi she became actress Parker
Posey
yeah yeah so Chad says you needed to
find what poor is
oh um I would yeah I had the like the
hole well I didn't even like have the
free lunch thing because we never did
that like I always just had to bring it
from home my dad works at a Oh Thank You
Nico Nico thing is is that represent
that you're not really supposed to mix
that I got it I got him a door in there
yeah he midori I [ __ ] with a lot of that
just think you're not really supposed to
mix that silver you can mix it's like
vodka but gold and represent a supposed
to just drink that on a rocks evidently
either I thought even though I do mix
them I do mix them well yeah but it's
wrong it's supposed to be wrong yeah
but yeah so I didn't so um my dad
actually like worked at a convenience
store so he would let me go in there and
like pick out like one thing like for my
lunch of the day so I would just like
have to pick like a pack of pop charts
or something like that like to take to
[ __ ] school one day I mean we lived
in a trailer park we lived in we mostly
had to live with relatives because a lot
of times my parents could not afford
rent so we usually had to live with
relatives and like I said most of my
clothes were secondhand from my older
cousins it kind of sucked you know and
like I said you go to school with like
upper-middle class kids they know that
you're wearing second-hand clothes or
you're wearing [ __ ] from [ __ ] Kmart
it's pitiful it is pitiful and they will
and they will like never ever let you
live it's like really so that's why I
still kind of have like a lingering
hatred for that whole type of culture
that whole like like I said like what
they used to call jock culture yeah but
bro culture and stuff like that because
those are like the types of people that
used to like [ __ ] on me and my friends
like you know they used to beat up my
friends my male friends were wearing
eyeliner and all that kind of [ __ ] so
it's I do not really like that kind of
people just saying so Zach's asking who
don't I know I know everybody we do know
a lot of I mean we know everybody you
know it's not like oh if I don't know if
I can find out I can find him if I don't
know I get we know a lot of people
around here
just that you don't necessarily want to
know what these people just want to hang
out they don't want the [ __ ] show
well you want okay good like I said it
goes you people we got a show we got a
do we'll socialize during the show well
yeah we can do that and like I said this
is just a grab bag it's just a grab bag
show we got some good [ __ ] you guys have
a bunch of fun [ __ ] yeah so let's talk
about the home now probably in the US
this is probably best known as the Taos
hum from Taos New Mexico however this
same phenomena has been reported in many
cities around the world including
Auckland New Zealand there's ones like
Ohio somewhere this one in Windsor
England all this kind of [ __ ] so what
they're not sure if the same thing is
causing all of this [ __ ] but it's
basically it's it's kind of like people
are hearing and it's usually only about
2% of people in an area that can hear
this persistent humming sound yeah it's
usually at a different frequency
somewhere between 32 Hertz and 80 Hertz
and as I said they've done studies
around the world where you know people
have heard a similar kind of sound or
they're describing a similar kind of
sound the most common description of it
is that it sounds like a diesel engine
running I believe this
you know why ibly well it's gotta be
something you know why I believe this
when I was a little kid and you can ask
well I don't they're not here but she
could ask my parents they would take me
into a store back in the 70s when I was
like 2 3 4 I'd start crying and then
when I got old enough to talk I could
remember it they would take me to these
stores and I could hear this
high-pitched squealing yeah all right
and it was only in certain stores I
could here's II you know kind of like
you know the emergency tested him yes he
broadcast isn't imagine it even higher
pitch than that and I could hear it in
certain stores eventually I couldn't
hear it anymore
went away as I got older and my
would be like what is it he's hearing
and the people that worked there was
thinking like I don't know and then one
guy came up with something that I
remembered and that they told me later
on my parents told when I got old enough
that I could hear the silent burglar
alarm oh it might have been maybe you
had like you know yeah
only as a little kid / sensitive hearing
and you like you can hear it anymore
yeah yeah when I got older I could hear
and I wonder if that's what some people
are hearing because they're silent
burglar alarm and certain and I don't
know right how you how that makes a
noise but there's some well it does but
it would be normally it would be outside
of the range of normal human hearing
yeah if you had like you know more
sensitive than usual hearing then you
might be able to hear like a hearing
which might be another thing that could
explain some of these strange like
humming sounds because like I said
generally only about 2% of people can
hear them a lot of other people can't
hear them so it might just be people
that are more sensitive to stuff that's
outside of the normal human range of
here I could remember man it was driving
at the wall I'd start screaming as a
little kid holding my ears shutting and
my dad would be like what's he hearing
Thank You Debra thank you very much
and the only thing that a guy came up
says I think he might be here in the
silent burglar alarm it's on I don't
know what a silent burglar alarm is or
how it works but it was in liquor stores
mostly and how many liquor source were
you in that you remember my dad take me
there all the time
well liquor stores in California sold
cigarettes
okay so he's going in there deep
cigarette sell cigarettes yeah we go in
there to get cigarettes
okay and and they all had alarms and
there's some about that alarm system and
maybe it was making a noise just yeah it
was just on yeah you know and I could
hear it it it sounded a little eerie
interesting because like I said you know
humans are variable and everybody has
kind of like different genetic
predispositions free elections whatever
so it stands to reason that some people
just as some people have you know less
than optimal hearing like me then some
people have like better than optimal
hearing and sometimes they can hear
things that other people cannot hear
which i think is probably what's going
on in the hum situation although I'm not
saying that
I don't think the same thing is
responsible for all of the hums around
the world because like I said people
have been reporting these types of
sounds and even though the sounds that
they're reporting fall within you know a
specific range
Jesus says liquor stores and banks I
think yeah you know anything more about
it man in the comments actually hit me
that would be interesting I've never
really seen that he or something as an
explanation
Thank You Nico thank you so much I'm
laughing at the little dancing Jason
damn I'm back and I missed my subject
you didn't miss anything yet you didn't
miss teeth we haven't even like as an
area we haven't we just started we just
love you people love you people all this
[ __ ] flashbulbs superstar I don't
necessarily at the people are hearing
silent burglar alarms I'm just saying
that they're hearing something outside
yeah and I definitely don't think I mean
yes there are probably cases where some
people thank you again thank you very
much I mean I definitely do feel like in
some cases that it might be tinnitus or
it might be you know somebody hearing
something like for example there was one
case in England where people were
reporting hearing a noise like in their
house and they couldn't get away with it
and they couldn't get away from it and
it turned out that there was a wasp's
nest inside the wall because they were
actually yeah so they were actually
hearing something but it wasn't kind of
like a huge but the thing about the Taos
hum and the Auckland home and everything
like that is that a lot of people are
reporting them even though it's not like
the majority of the population enough
people are reporting it that I figure
it's probably some outside source yeah
well though there might be a thing to
where the more like if somebody reports
it then somebody else might be listening
for it I don't like to hear it out of
like I don't think so but I'm saying
that's a possibility I believe that
there's something generating a frequency
in a sir
percentage of the people can hear it
it's gonna be like like I'm saying me as
a little kid I could hear some kind of
whining coming out of them like bees
nests said banks and liquor stores I
could hear only when I was a little kid
yeah well yeah you might have like I
said you might have just had like really
super sensitive hearing right when I was
but then as you get older you're sent
you know your Anka's my hearing has
deteriorated I mean my hearings been
[ __ ] by the time I was maybe eight or
nine I couldn't hear it anymore
yeah it was only when I was a very
little kid Sheila says what about that
hum down in Cuba at the Embassy we are
gonna talk we're gonna talk about that
we're gonna probably be the last thing
we talk about but yeah that is on my
list that the Havana Syndrome we're
going to talk about that um but yeah but
look Maria says Tom I can hear that
sound in stores as well I think it was
about the kind of alarm system they used
back then yes I believe so they it might
have been older people can't hear it
that high frequency that kid yeah it was
like he was almost like sent likes like
a gunshot went off and your ears were
ringing that's what it sounded loud I
hate that and in that a lot like it was
deep in there and randomly I be in their
arms and they'd carry me in there and it
would just be screaming it was [ __ ]
they would drive me up the goddamn wall
so it wasn't just me yeah it wasn't just
me um certain little kids could hear it
I can see how dogs probably yeah the
dogs are probably going ape [ __ ] can you
imagine like poor little pumps and it's
like they have to listen to this [ __ ]
noise all the time and they're just like
please turn it off it's like the weird
thing about but the weird thing about my
hearing it's like I've been I found
hearing problems since since I was a
very young teenager like I with
medication and everything I can still
hear but it's very um you know it people
have to be like I have to be looking at
you especially if there's like ambient
noise I can't really hear what people
are saying it just sounds like you know
the McDonald's drive-thru speaker um
and I always have to put like [ __ ]
closed captioning on even if it's in
English because I can't really make out
a lot of people's dialogue so so I've
had that since I was a teenager they
told me actually that I would be deaf by
the time like when I went to the doctor
I was 15 maybe
14:15 they told me I'd be deaf by the
time I was 20 which I wasn't thankfully
told me I'd never walk again after my
motorcycle I mean it's like what you're
saying yeah they're just saying but it's
like in my doing the world case my
hearing is not good
but I'm not completely deaf honestly but
the weird thing about it too is that
certain types of noises are very very
very annoying to me so so it's like I
can't hear but then the noises that I
can hear like kind of drive me nuts you
know I mean so a lot of times like I
have a noise white noise generator and
stuff like that's like drown it's like
you know that like the lawn crew kind of
noises and stuff like that it's like
kind of drives me crazy so I have to
turn that off but yeah so the hum noise
is particularly the Taos hum now one
person that has heard the hum said that
the range of it and I'm not sure I'm
sure they probably like drove her and
attest this they said that the range of
it was 30 miles so they could hear it
for 30 miles and then like outside of
that I guess they didn't hear it anymore
so there does Studies on this particular
the Taos hum in particular they said
between men and women is about even
although they did say that it was more
common for people like middle-aged
people to hear it rather than like
younger people are older people so
that's that's kind of the only
demographic sort of thing that's like
making it thing she even said you two
are medical miracles what those [ __ ]
do when you get hurt is they give you
the worst case scenario you'll never
walk again
oh you'll never hear again and then when
you get better they that doctor goes to
see on the greatest I'm the greatest
doctor in the world unfixed you I think
what they're doing is they're dreamy
chariot imaging your expertise and also
they might be it might be like some
reverse psychology because they're kind
of like triggering your goddammit I'm
gonna make a because you know what and
here's the thing like my mom was in like
a horrible horrible car accident she was
like hit head-on and it crushed her arm
in her leg she had to have like metal
bars put in there and they told her the
same thing they're like you're probably
not gonna walk again and you're never
gonna harm Lee again and she told me
that she was like well that just made me
more determined to like to like walk
again just despite them you know what a
kiss bite is a very powerful thing she
does she still walks with a limp but
it's not actually
all that bad so I I do think that they I
think they know what they're doing you
know what I mean I don't think there's
actual recuperative abilities yeah bite
a flight response they're trying to get
you to fight the injury yeah yeah I mean
I don't know how much that went into it
like with my hearing because I don't
know how much control of is it's not
kind of like I had couldn't that much
control over my hearing but they did I
mean I had to take like these horrible
tasting pills and stuff like that like
all through my teenage years for my ears
and I have like they had people are
always sticking things in my ears and
taking [ __ ] it was terrible but um
I'm actually glad I'm super I'm almost
50 and I'm not completely deaf I can
still hear but these nests am will love
this 5-hour show at least we started
yeah if we just started at 7 it wouldn't
have been done until like midnight it
had it been like and I'd been like
falling asleep doing this at 5 o'clock
our time there's [ __ ] none of the
clubs are open anyway where's it's
Saturday night it's like we don't have
anything else to do I called I called
Tom and I said Tom you commuting Tom
yeah big time I'm gonna introduce you
guys a big Tom big Tom is red yeah big
to big Tom's this big old [ __ ] black
guy that I've known him for years at the
club and he bought his own [ __ ] bar
near us and he's treatment talking about
for years cuz we met him at I bar which
is like our favorite place yeah he
wanted me to come in there as his
manager he's like I want to open my own
place and he finally did yeah he did and
I said dude you don't need me man
[ __ ] and he [ __ ] that's got a
[ __ ] bad-ass little [ __ ] bar going
he's gonna get it it's horror-themed
yeah and it's closed gonna get the place
next door and knock the wall out [ __ ]
put a dance dance dance yeah the dance
floor but it's pretty yeah it's too
small and he's gonna make it bigger his
landlord loves him let's just hook these
lock downs and and [ __ ] these
[ __ ] are playing games behind
these locked outs
I'm gonna unlock this [ __ ] I'm
gonna lock this muhfucka they're not
gonna have a say in it I'm gonna have to
take [ __ ] away from them
they're abusing it they are abusing it I
mean he can still rise up like the
immortan I take control over this
[ __ ] tell him to open up okay
yeah yeah oh
so you see it you're gonna see all right
so now like I said this whole home
phenomenon like I said it's not just the
Taos I'm at several other homes around
the world so there is still some
controversy
thank you very much music Nico see
whenever I talk crazy Nico I'm gonna
start talking crazy it's not crazy it's
sanity it's just that it goes against
other people never mind well I don't
know because there's sanity the great
the craziest person always insists that
they're not crazy I had this all figured
out don't worry about it let me do a
bigger plan
alright that's part of a bigger plan
okay I've got the [ __ ] all wargames and
mapped out already he's got it all
figured out you guys yeah so I want to
see Tom pole dance you know that's
something that we all you [ __ ] put me
in these sexual situations not even pole
dance yeah heat pole dance yeah my
birthday party our friend angel your
birthday party for me and her agent last
year the year before long time ago no it
was it was two years ago yeah
yeah this way it was two years ago three
four maybe yeah maybe 2017 maybe 2016
hard to say but yeah they had a fire pit
there it's like I just Lee like I went
in the back room that I was talking to
Toby and some other people about true
crime and I just kept Jordan gonna drink
it and it's like I don't ever wanna [ __ ]
I guess it was two years ago because I
think it was like you're getting big
yeah um it wasn't lesson Toby is that
herb is my buddy that's for [ __ ]
leather daddy buddy he's like [ __ ]
Billy
he's like Rob Halford Rob now he's older
than you he's older than me yeah that
sexy [ __ ] or not you would never
guess that though that sexy [ __ ]
right there gasps [ __ ] can pull more
want women than a man could ever do is
he's rad he'd be out there in that tight
ass [ __ ] leather [ __ ] with this
little [ __ ] shirt on dancing like that
you watching him yes get out and I'll be
back
they're laughing and they're staring at
his crotch he's got that [ __ ] going on
like a 40-ounce [ __ ] going around his
[ __ ] just like a imagine you took a
40 ounce beer and put an apple on the
end of it and then wrap that [ __ ] around
your [ __ ] leg okay that's how that
[ __ ] is these women just staring
at it well yeah I wanna dance for like a
second dance naked dance is he looking
guys in good shape he's just [ __ ] I
mean is do you understand like woman's
psychology why do you think they love
gay men and he and I'll tell you what
he's only gay when he's straight or
ensues me he's only gay when he's sweet
he's sold over soon as he gets drunk
he's all over her I got a [ __ ]
getting between him [ __ ] separated
that's [ __ ] ridiculous
and then he pretends it didn't happen
man worry about that he turns straight
[ __ ] drown yeah hello you gotta have
him on the show come on yeah he wanted
he wanted to [ __ ] uh me to be his
physical trainer oh that's right he was
gonna come over like before lockdown
things like I wanna he's gonna come over
like workout in your man cave yeah yeah
in the garage yeah but yeah so so when
we were at that party like I said cuz I
just went off on the [ __ ] screened-in
porch and I was like drinking with them
and like talking about murders and [ __ ]
cuz that's what I do at parties but you
got drunk and you got on the pole
because why are we bringing this [ __ ] up
for some reason at Angel's house yes she
has a stripper pole yeah I know that
[ __ ] this is the kind of people that
it's like it's a totally normal here's a
bar in that house - well yeah [ __ ]
bottle up the Trump they did yeah but
yeah she says it's a totally normal
looking house it just as a stripper pole
in the living room and so he decided he
was gonna get a stripper pole there's
video of it somewhere but I don't yeah I
can traverse like think she posted yeah
I was looking good - yeah was it was yes
I'm good yeah I think I missed it but I
saw the video and there's a whole bottle
of patron it was it wasn't a big bottle
of patron it was a small about drop but
angels husband they're married right I'm
not sure
Arsene man you never can tell with the
Flex car well because some people are
together but then there's like others
yeah and then yes sometimes the size
that were the Gerry polyamorous yeah
some tutors I don't want to like step on
anybody's shoes like a group of them
yeah that's what I mean everyone's like
into polyamory so mentally sure it's all
God's people yeah and God's people are
all kind of like the same sex yeah it's
like a unisex thing and they're all like
multi-sexual yeah it's just because
everybody and everybody knows everybody
knows everybody just like I mean it's
like a gang sort of kind of like a gang
weird [ __ ] so and it's not on purpose it
just evolved into that yeah everybody
just kind of doesn't everybody's just
there's no defensive people aren't very
defensive that's what it is yeah
everybody just likes each other yeah
it's weird like for the most part it
really does seem like everybody's like
there's like little petty dramas here
and there but we got to get back on
stuff we probably knew multi-sexual
never not my suit well I just so this is
what we're saying so it's oh the home
thing like I said since it's been kind
of like reported at different places
around then they're not really sure if
like the same source is responsible um
so there has been some skepticism like I
said some scientists have said that
maybe it's you know two percent of the
people maybe they have tinnitus or maybe
it's a thing where somebody heard about
it and then so they're more receptive to
hearing [ __ ] that maybe other people are
like they're focusing more on a noise in
the environment that they wouldn't
normally notice because there is a thing
where because the inside of your ears
like make noise on their own you know
what I mean so if you're in a completely
silent environment and you hear a noise
that might not necessarily be a noise
that's like outside of your body it
might be something that's like making
noise inside of your head I mean that is
a thing
because it does make noise in there so
some people are saying that maybe it's
that but I don't know I did feel like
it's maybe something that's outside
they're just not really entirely sure
what it might be so here are all the
possible explanations so as I said a lot
of the people that have reported this
particular sound not everybody but a lot
of people that are reported it said it
sounded sounds kind of like a diesel
engine now some of the places where this
has been reported for example Kokomo
Indiana um they had a hum now they
thought that the hum had probably come
from a cooling tower at the Daimler
Chrysler casting plant because that was
putting out a noise at about 36 Hertz
which was right there in that little
sweet spot where people were hearing it
um there was also the Haynes
International plant that had like an air
compressor that was making a noise it
was like about ten Hertz so they said
either of those things or a combination
of those things could have been causing
the hum in that particular situation so
in some cases it could be like some
mechanical particularly like I said
because a lot of people have described
it it's like sounding like a diesel
engine so a lot of people have said well
maybe it's some kind of machinery that's
running and some people are picking up
on that and maybe other people like 98
percent of people are probably not
noticing it because it's just like
background noise but maybe some people
that are really sensitive to sound or
whatever are hearing it and attributing
it to something else but it might just
be something like mechanical thing
what's that I they're asking about
they're asking about Toby but I was
going to show a picture Toby but then I
came across this one
I came approaches wait I can't see what
you do oh by Maria galley oh yeah okay
she had a fever mom I know I know how
that goes yeah I saw this [ __ ]
picture there's like sorry laughing go
ahead just oh that picture yeah that's
me
me and Dave have me Jenny and like a
couple these porn star girls we know
yeah yeah I was gonna show um that's
fine
hey we're asking about Toby doesn't it
show you've got a picture of it yeah
cool just keep going oh this is this is
the girl where I was on the [ __ ]
unit end that was the angel it's gonna
show me oh oh yeah I had the [ __ ]
angel be excited cuz she listens
sometimes yeah I don't know if change
what goes on shows all tired or no she's
on here right now angel was actually a
survivalist
that's angel there in the front yeah
that's angel between us
yeah that's re green yeah go ahead give
her your phone I gotta shake it like it
was like it was a what Iike what do you
call those things a [ __ ] uh Myra
graph yes I got a [ __ ] I gotta go I
gotta find Toby okay all right Toby
there's a look at the rob halford a
[ __ ] Orlando he's a paramedic writer
you know he's a nurse a nurse yeah I
thought I knew who's unlike the medical
field
yeah um let's see all right so we're
talking about all right I just keep
waiting because I know you're gonna like
no no go ahead go ahead
so now they have found two particular
homes in two particular cities that have
been attributed to what they now know
her mechanical sources so like I said it
could be that all of the city ones like
do you have an actual source and then
it's mechanical there was a hum in West
Seattle and this was actually found to
be there was a this company called Cal
Portland and they offloaded cargo from
ships and they had like a vacuum pump
and that was what was making the noise
cuz I guess it wasn't there all the time
and just like some people heard it like
temporarily and then do you wonder what
it was but they actually did kind of
trace it to that
so they found out that once they
replaced the silencers on that
particular machine that nobody reported
the hum anymore so they figured that's
probably it was now the one that's in
Wellington New Zealand they thought that
was also a diesel generator on a ship
that was that had come up to the port
there was also one in Windsor Ontario
which is that 35 Hertz and they think
that that came from like a steel works
or like you know a still works factory
near Detroit now there is also a hum in
Myrtle Beach South Carolina and they
think that this came from a Santee
Cooper substation this is like it has
like a really big transformer in it this
is the largest transformer in South
Carolina
now this particular transformer I guess
once they figured out that that was what
was causing the noise like they had some
people that lived in the city like suing
the company because the noise was so
disruptive to them that they were like
arguing mental distress or physical
distress or something like that okay oh
you did I found two hopefully oh yeah
that was a while back yeah okay there's
good I can't see it won't focus it won't
focus it focus for a second they focus
for a second that's Toby right there
yeah well that kind of happens every
time we go it goes at the castle yeah
[Laughter]
yeah the thing about this particular one
and why this particular couple sued this
company was because from their point of
view like the hum they heard it all the
time but the hum they said it was louder
inside their house than outside
and once they determined like what the
source of the hum was all they could
figure was that their house was like
resonating at the same frequency as the
hum so it was like amplifying it like
inside
and it was like driving them nuts so
they actually did sue the company I'm
not really sure how that came out
because that seems like it would be a
really hard thing to prove um like I
said some people have also said that
tinnitus was responsible but you know
this is just 2% of people and there's
like hearing ringing in their ears and
they're attributing it to an outside
source so but the thing about it though
is that that can't be responsible for
all of the hums that are recorded around
the world because some people still
report that you know they hear them like
outdoors and indoors it's like some
people don't hear it it you know some
people hear it all the time which like I
said that would seem more like tinnitus
but some people only hear it in a
particular area and then when they go
outside of there at that area they don't
hear it anymore some people that have
complained about it say that it's
actually sometimes if you soundproof
your house like with double glazed
windows there's no like that it actually
makes it worse because it like it gets
rid of other ambient sounds and makes
that sound like stand out more you know
so alright what are you looking at now
piece of ice fell out Oh
now as I mentioned earlier um human ears
make their own sounds this is called
spontaneous otoacoustic emissions or SOA
II now 38 to 60 percent of people of
adults with normal hearing have these
types of things and like I said if
you've ever sat in like a normal you
know or in like a really silent
environment um you know kind of sensory
deprivation or anything like that and
you still hear a noise that is actually
your ears producing that noise it's not
like coming from outside so some people
have argued that maybe the hum could be
that there's also kind of like there's
some weird [ __ ] where it could be like I
said in a lot of cases it's mechanical
you know diesel engines or you know
something from like a ship or something
like that also in some cases might be
insects because you know crickets
cicadas
stuff like that do cause these types of
you know sounds so let's see there's
also oh there's some other [ __ ] in
nature to not just crickets and whatnot
but there's also this this fish called
the midshipman fish and apparently it
has like a mating call that kind of
sounds like that kind of sounds like
what people are describing in certain
situations as one of the hum kind of
sounds so there was one hum that was
recorded in Sausalito California that
they later determined was probably the
mating call of the male Midshipmen fish
which was making this particular
frequency sound that some people were
picking up on although that particular
case was just mostly it wasn't people
that lived inland necessarily it was
just people that lived on houseboats and
they were just like they were hearing
the sound like this fish was making like
calling the lady midshipman fish and it
was like vibrating or like echoing
against the boat hulls of these people's
houseboats and so they were like hearing
this amplified noise and they didn't
know what it was or where it was coming
from so that's where that was but like I
said [ __ ] them's more inland not
necessarily Zach talking more about Toby
there Toby Zach he's a rad dude actually
yes and it he's constantly attracting
these damn women
well that's Tracy yeah yeah she moved
away yeah so let's see so like I said
could be fish could be crickets could be
any number of different things could be
machines of various types like I said
anytime you have something like and I
think even on the x-files like they did
a show about they did something where
they kind of referred to the taos home
and I think it was kind of like it was
aliens and all this other kind of [ __ ]
but I think in most of the cases it's
probably oh thank you again Nico yeah I
think it's probably
I think it's probably just like a
mundane source it's just that not
everyone maybe not everyone hears it not
everyone is aware of it what okay those
are ups he's like got a piggy bye
so like I said I'm not said I don't
think there's anything mysterious about
I don't think it's aliens or anything
like that but it's interesting to me
because in a lot of cases they don't
really know where the source of it is
although in many cases I think it's
probably just you know it's a machine
somewhere that is running that certain
people can like tune into that
particular frequency and it's like
bothering them or something like there
could be something like in nature like I
said like a cricket sound or something
like that so I also want to talk a
little bit about um I kind of went up to
wait till Tom gets back although it says
Toby super hot I just sketched thank you
I could not remember the name of that
for anything that's what happens when
you get old you can't remember [ __ ]
anymore
I was thinking [ __ ] I was like what's
that thing like your skin you know like
you're shaking it like it's a Polaroid
picture like that [ __ ] song I don't
know but yeah little horny fishies
humming that's exactly what they were
it's like that's that's like that oh
that kills me that that's like the
little [ __ ] fish and they're just
like making humming sounds and people
are here in the boats being like what
the [ __ ] is that why are you making like
and I think - I mean we'll talk about
this later but there's a whole thing
about the Havana syndrome I don't it's
like I'd never heard of it before it's
like I kind of heard of it a couple
years ago because it's pretty recent but
it's like particularly you know
particularly people its ambassadors US
and Canadian ambassadors like in Havana
Cuba have been reporting like these
really like physical symptoms and they
have actually found they have actually
found like physical you know evidence of
like what they're suffering like with
MRIs and [ __ ] and they report hearing
this like weird noise and everything and
I don't know if that's like something
that somebody is doing to them like a
sort of sonic attack or something or if
it's just like something in nature that
is causing that like maybe like some
kind of Crick
it noise like at a particular frequency
which some people have put forward or
something of that type I'm not really
sure because there are kind of like
sounds in nature that can mimic these
type of sounds that would like you know
give people like physical kind of like
um symptoms like they have seen in the
havana syndrome so like I said we'll get
into that a little bit but uh you are
you doing all right yeah you need take a
break yeah let me get let me get her
take a break go to the bathroom for a
second or commercial pause you get in
there all right see what everybody else
is up to okay yeah mangos saying see the
Rob hell yeah
yeah for the Toby Toby's pretty cool man
I know I'm not telling you Toby first
[ __ ] [ __ ] ten years it's just [ __ ]
man I was telling him I was just like
man you're denying isn't you're denying
these women your essence because this
dude is so [ __ ] popular with women
but he doesn't date him that's not where
he's at
but when he gets drunk he's [ __ ] all
he's all over Jenny and you know he will
start [ __ ] [ __ ] around with women
and [ __ ] but then like his friends
[ __ ] save him you know it's [ __ ]
funny man it's just way he is what
Toby's number I don't have his phone
number man but I can get you in contact
with him you're taking no Zach you can't
you can't be cheating on your Jewish
boyfriend
he'll [ __ ] come on he'll come at you
with a gang of lawyers or some [ __ ] that
was quick
she's as quick as a man she calls me
dude who she is sleeping in the cat tree
just right outside of the hall there she
was like she was in the little Bowl and
I went out there to go to the bathroom
and she just looked at me the look of
the bow like exam oh yeah I'm so sleepy
it's storming outside so she doesn't
want to go outside yeah she's sleeping
all right so yeah they make sure
everybody's back from the break they're
saying I'm matchmaking between these
gays yeah yeah Tom a gay matchmaker you
do Trent like trying to do that because
well Toby's always looking for well a
lot of times that's the main
reproductive strategy between gay men is
to get their straight friends to go out
and find them her man well you're like
his wingman yeah you know gotta fight of
a [ __ ] man he's I gotta admit though
Zach there Mickey
I got a knit those act
you know I don't know if you're man
enough [ __ ] Toby Toby likes [ __ ]
macho [ __ ] he likes ya he likes
[ __ ] he likes warrior gays warrior
gays you know yeah he's so good that's
bad about he talks bad about [ __ ]
[Laughter]
yeah very much so
he's testosterone driven you know you
something else
Sandra said I'm tiny I'm actually not
that tiny I'm actually quite large no
you know tiny wait honey I'm short yes
sure sure yeah
5 4 - maybe what do you what are you
[ __ ] do you want to talk about the
bloop and other unidentifiable and aboot
the ocean yeah now it was a weird case
well I don't know if it's all that weird
but I need to stop distracting from the
show trying to sell off my gay friends
and [ __ ] I know Toby's gonna think be
like what are you doing tom I gotta have
him on the show why did he dressed up
like a cowboy he dressed doesn't want
his cowboy outfits
[Laughter]
ok so yeah alright so like I said the
bloop is actually not the only it's not
actually the bloop it's just a balloon
so he goes who's Toby
yeah have you been watching the [ __ ]
Toby's my gay friend I showed pictures
of it well one of our games several but
yeah so it's not kind of like a hope my
black friend oh my gay friend it's like
yeah so the thing about the bloop is
that like I said it's just called the
bloop or just called bloop not the bloop
which is very funny to me because the
first thing that it reminded me of and I
don't know if you guys are remember this
or it's just like me peeing
weird but do you remember I think it was
a Pink Panther cartoon and there was a
Pink Panther cartoon where there was a I
think he was an art thief and he was
like a little blotch but he was called
the blue ch
do you remember that no and he was just
kind of like and he could disguise
himself is like artwork like cuz he was
just like a little blotch of red yeah he
was like a little villain and so he
would like kind of go up in the canvas
and be like what I'm just like a
painting what do you talk to cartoon
Pink Panther yeah yeah not like not like
the movies with Peter Sellers I remember
that cartoon that well yeah the blue CH
and he was like French I want to say
alright at like a French exit I remember
mr. Magoo am I am I crazy or am I
remembering that wrong is it a fever
dream I don't really know but I'm pretty
sure like the blue CH was a real thing
but it's like so every time I hear bloop
I think it's that little cartoon that's
probably just maybe it's my squid all
right so like I said bloop is not the
only like weird noise that they've
recorded in the ocean um you know the
Noa of National Oceanic and Atmospheric
Administration because they have like
this big array of essentially
microphones like over the water and
they're recording like all these like
weird noises and [ __ ] so the bloop was
only one of those that was like unusual
they're pretty sure they maybe know what
caused it but I don't know if it's ever
gonna be like definitive that that's
what it is but another one that they
recorded like I said goes bloop wasn't
the only one they also recorded one
called upsweep and this is an
unidentified sound that was detected on
their you know their hydrophone arrays
or their microphone arrays and they this
was in 1991 in august of 91 and it's
like these it's like these ups who they
call it up sweet because it's like the
the sounds are a few seconds each and I
guess they kind of like go it's narrow
band up sweeping I'm not like an audio
expert so I'm not entirely sure what
that means but I guess like you know so
it's so when our bees are saying the
bloop is whale sex I disagree the boob
the bloop is now I think it's icebergs
because this the intensity and the
[ __ ] wavelength
because you would have [ __ ] bloop
constantly because the whales are kind
of [ __ ] constantly oh no whales man
well yeah what else have they got to do
thank you yeah they'd be like whales
you'd hear it all the time I mean like I
what else have whales got to do on this
we're just gonna see them around and eat
stuff and then we're the wheels make
little wheels the feels the wheels only
[ __ ] once and it come in a kit showed
up on this nothing it would be 24/7 24/7
well in whale sexcapades it would be
[ __ ] fest I feel like this is a whole
poor Giles in 20 this is all part that's
right whale sex yeah well like I said in
season because most other than humans
like most animals have a sex season
which is very weird to me but you know
I'm even so I don't I don't want to be
species issed
but you know are we the only we're the
only species that don't have that right
yeah that's how we survived yeah because
back in back in prehistoric times ice
ages and stuff you just had to get it on
when you when you could somebody is
going cuz there's somebody if there's a
cave lead yeah there you go let's go get
it because go get that yeah they know
through examinations of our DNA that the
living people of today only descend from
a very small group of people
well you meant that there was an
evolutionary about there is an
evolutionary well and we're not the only
human-like species that there was Nkosi
and shears tom thank you very much and
it's several of them like we're alive at
the same time yeah so which is very
funny to me because they didn't know
that
like just 100 years ago 50 years ago
they didn't know that that there were
like more than one species of human like
cohabiting yeah like lions and tigers
and prey it is they're all big cats but
they're different and then some of them
enter bread because they're we you know
close enough humans were like that but
it seems to be through the examination
of DNA the people that are alive today
descended from a very small amount of
survivors or some kind of
apocalypse probably an ice age and some
of them had interbred with Neanderthals
well yeah they they know that for sure
yeah there was all cut it was mostly
European it was probably a long time ago
because there's not like a huge amount
left in the DNA signature it seems like
it seems to be that the races that exist
today are basically descendants of
different families really that survived
that apocalypse their far-flung families
some of them at interbred with other
species it's weird it's weird well like
I said they keep coming up with new I
mean do you know new human like I don't
take human like they were humans but
it's like you know they were just
different slightly different species but
it's not even slightly different species
because if you're close to have to
reproduce
thank you again Niko no also then
they're then that's not it technically
that's not a different species but
because you can still interbreed yeah
but it's weird because evidently mankind
had kind of spread out in a different
species but not very far from one
another where they were different
species but they had viable offspring
like I said the definition of a species
is whether you can interbreed and
have-nots and have offspring that are
viable like that yeah they can reproduce
yeah my experience from the [ __ ]
horse industry that's not a real that
that's a very fast and loose rule you
can you can crossbreed a horse and a
donkey and get a mule and they say that
a mule is sterile but not always most of
the time sometimes both sit down there
sometimes a mule just because it's been
such a long term sense yes it just
depends on it's it's it's still in that
grey area where it could go this way but
it every now and then a mule can breed
back in with a horse which means that if
you know what if you don't watch it in
the horse breeding world or in the horse
world it's possible you might
accidentally create horses that have
this donkey DNA in them yeah well that's
happened to the humans evidently
especially when you look at Europeans
Europeans are partly Anatol and probably
a human and Indiana talk and Interbrew
but the offspring mostly was a [ __ ]
viable yeah
but some of them were yeah that's us but
like I said that's kind of like that's
like at the tail end of like a
speciation you know what I mean it's a
you know it's not like a this species
that species it's like you know my
accent then you might have some black
match some nationalists come out and go
yeah I knew those Bologna smelling
[ __ ] up in the cave or [ __ ]
cavemen yeah the thing is is that white
people and black people are
interbreeding so therefore there's some
of that Neanderthal DNA and black people
to say we all are related where certain
extent or another that's kind of
comforting in a way yeah all right um
somebody said dolphins are also having
sex for pleasure see here's what I
always thought though I always feel like
probably all animals are having sex for
pleasure because I don't know like
they're driven to it like however far
down you know the you know the
evolutionary chain you want to go let's
let's say that um so I do feel like do
animals like cats dogs whatever
do they have an understanding that when
they have sex they are reproducing do
they understand that or did they just
understand hey I gotta [ __ ] somethin so
I would argue that all animals are
having sex for pleasure yeah because I
don't think that they they're not fully
cognizant that's what's driving them
that that's what I'm not saying that
they don't know that sex leads to
reproduction no but I'm just saying that
they're not really thinking about it to
the extent that we would think of it oh
yeah it's just like that's all I'm
saying all I can do is just watch Ken he
tries I can get on yeah you tell that's
well yeah they will just hump your leg
yeah that's lost we took some and you
guys will find this very funny so Pookie
went into was she was she had an
appointment to go get fixed yeah and
about a week or two before the
appointment she went into heat yeah and
we do remember we video of it it's like
it I felt so bad for her she was just
like she was on the kitchen floor and
she was like making this terrible that
was like
she was just like sticking your butt up
at us and stuff that was just like oh my
god but it was so so funny and I and I
ended up I think I called the video
little pawn for her yeah yeah like the
vulcans
that's what I need I don't remember if I
ever posted anywhere because I felt so
bad and I'm like you're gonna get fixed
in two weeks it's like please just like
hang out but until then and it's like I
felt so bad but yeah so I I would argue
that all animals have sex for pleasure
because I don't think they know I also
could argue that contrary to what I used
to believe and what scientists used to
say when I was a kid I believed pretty
much all mammals are conscious I think
that birds are conscious they're know
for sure they're not very intelligent
all the time open well it depends on the
type of bird pens on what you call
intelligence they're they know that they
are they they have a feeling of being
they know the things is I do think that
to a certain extent mammals and probably
a lot of bird species are self-aware
yeah at least that I mean I think that
there might be more
you know what arguments be made for
quote-unquote whatever yeah he ever said
that only humans really I don't believe
in conscious and then they are using
mirrors as tests and chimps could
something could pass it some great apes
could pass it but I think dogs and cats
kind of they just react differently to a
mirror I believe they know they exist
well the thing we were we were kind of
interested to see how Pookie would react
to a mirror because like I said that
seems to be like the go to
self-awareness test like when they're
testing self-awareness and animals and
I've seen like um videos of cats dogs
whatever and they some of them react to
a mirror as though it's another
individual and like they want to fight
it some of them seem to know that that's
them Pookie reacts to it like she looks
in it she will look at us in it like if
like our bathroom mirror we have this
big like wall size like you know mirror
in the bathroom
and if you look in the bathroom mirror
you can see somebody's sitting on the
bed in the bedroom she will look in the
mirror in the bathroom
and see me sitting on the bed and she
just looks and she act like it's normal
so she treats the mirror like a human
would treat the mirror like it's no big
Sandra said the paint that sex for cat
female cats is painful so they're not
doing it for the pleasure I disagree
well okay because you have to understand
the [ __ ] it's kind of like BDSM those
people they're driven to do it just
because it hurts doesn't mean they don't
like it well I could show you couples
where this is true okay doesn't mean
they don't like it it's you know because
and and all animal sex basically when
you look at these animals if you were to
try to judge it by human standards it's
rape so it's immoral it is but
particularly in ducks yeah go watch that
[ __ ] but the thing is is that your
project and human standards on them
they're not humans they're animalistic
they're [ __ ] sex is like BDSM it's
also very brief yeah just like video
they don't really know what happened
they don't understand it but they're
driven to do it I don't know I I feel
like maybe they understand it but it's
just kind of like well that's how it
goes
they don't go about their day they're
very silly I guess I gotta go find some
fish now yeah like I said the whole duck
thing if you guys have never seen like
ducks it like don't Google that but
seriously because the well there's like
an arms race going on between the male
and the female ducks because the males
have like that that corkscrew-shaped yes
which like I said no Google [ __ ] comes
out like and down and so all the female
yes so the female ducks have like tried
to evolve this kind of like it's like
the reverse quarter but it's also kind
of like yes so duck ducks are not
they're not cool animals there that's a
rapist birds and dinosaurs are very
different from us you got to look at
[ __ ] mammals
you know [ __ ] mammals are a lot
closer to us putting cats dogs big cats
[ __ ] wolves and [ __ ] [ __ ] even
elephants there are a lot closer to us
you can understand their behavior
well a lot of mammals particularly and
even some birds and somebody mentioned
up
upstream crows and ravens I've read
several books by ornithologist that like
raised crows and ravens crows and ravens
are actually or the core big group are
actually a lot more intelligent thank
you very much
Sultana thank you mrs. mrs. Sultan where
is the soultana from but yes so I so
crows and ravens are actually like much
more intelligent than some monkeys even
some apes are better at problem solving
and then some apes are so they have some
I mean they did some [ __ ] like I read
this book called
the mind of the Raven I think this by I
think his name was a burn Heydrich or
something like that and he's like a
ornithologist and he raises them like he
has an enclosure like in his backyard
and he has a bunch of them and he like
devices all these tests for them to do
and some of the [ __ ] that they did was
like [ __ ] that monkeys couldn't do or it
took them much longer for the monkeys to
figure out so you know some birds
particularly birds of prey tend to be
not quite as smart but for some reason
like crows Ravens stuff like that
because what they do is they get meat
and they hide it and then they come back
later and find it and they have like
this really elaborate system for like
storing things and then like doing back
later remember it was just different
difficult to measure it is on the
environment humans can do that
chimpanzees can but chimpanzees can do
things that humans can chimpanzees can
remember their memories are much better
than they are yeah they can their
short-term memory is way better they can
remember a long series of shapes far
beyond what a human can do it's weird
and chimps are very chimps and apes are
real cognizant of [ __ ] they have a
very good spatial awareness and a good
awareness of body language cuz they
don't they're not verbal you know they
don't have language so everything's
about where you're sitting and how far
away you are like what face how you
carrying yourself they're very much into
that
we gotta keep moving what else is going
on this thing no I'm just saying well
human intelligence human intelligence is
good at tool
making and figuring things out but you
don't want to underestimate other animal
intelligences and it's like humans are
not specialized we're generalized yeah
and so it just happens that we're
generalized in particular ways that like
make us kind of like more well-rounded
and [ __ ] right we're a man for all
seasons humans can do a little bit of
everything I always thought that like
and I even thought that's this when I
was a teenager it's like I always feel
like when they give animals intelligence
tests I'm like yeah but we designed
those intelligence tests and it's like
not really the same intelligence that is
necessary in their environment so I'm
not sure that intelligence as a generic
concept is only all that valuable
because you know it intelligence depends
on the environment that you were in you
gotta look at it this way
most animals are specialized they're
specialized for for a very specific
niche in the environment specializations
short term is a great survival strategy
strategy not so much long term long term
generalization is a lot better that way
with the environment changes if a
[ __ ] volcano goes off the [ __ ]
meteor hits it the [ __ ] if the earth
[ __ ] gets tilted on its axis you
could survive it you have to be a jabra
tree well you have to be willing to
cooperate with others of your species to
kind of like figure out what are we
gonna do if this happens what would you
have to have contingency that's only
part of it I'm saying that I'm saying
that you need a generalized intelligence
right so you go well you know what I
can't be a woodpecker anymore I gotta be
Eagle well if you've evolved into being
a woodpecker you're never gonna be an
eagle you don't tell them ah yeah but if
you have a more generalized bird that
can be a woodpecker or an eagle then it
would have a chance to survive and in an
apocalypse generalization long term is
the way to go flexibility do you think
flexibility that's what general is
anyways yeah generalization yep so
humans are generalized that you can do a
little bit of everything and that's why
we've survived but our ancestors were
the weakest of all animals yeah we
didn't have any over we don't have as
long that's how many teeth we'd have
anything that's how we got generalized
we're just like a bunch of naked
little puppets going language and told
me if we weren't smart we'd have done
language fool making that was the
difference well yeah it can only come
from generalization yeah okay yeah
somebody said Ravens they can be jerks
sometimes we'll follow you around the
parking lot well because they remember
faces that's why they remember two
particular people people that were mean
to them in the past even years ago in
the past that was another thing that I
learned from that book is that Ravens
will for sure remember if you did
something shitty and they will never
forget what your face looks like so only
three things will survive the apocalypse
roaches roaches crows and bums highly
generalized they don't like it they
don't give a [ __ ] and they know how to
like honey badgers why don't chicken fly
well they don't need to anymore we went
from bloops to Biddy MCAT sex that's
just what happens on this [ __ ] show
the more alcohol that is consumed the
less we've and Telfer I don't even got
look for almost two hours into this
[ __ ] show and I'm only unlike my
second topic this is what happens when
you let him talk so yeah anyway so you
got your up sweep sound like I said they
don't really know what this is if you
guys even remember what I'm talking
about this was first measured in 1991
and it's kind of like this weird
auditory like absolute kind of sounds
several seconds at a time they think
that it might be natural perhaps because
it is seasonal this Peaks are in spring
and autumn but they don't they're not
really sure if this is because it's
something natural like say a natural
animal that's making this noise or if
it's just because the environmental
factor factors are making it like easier
to record the sound for example because
I you know I don't like I said I'm not
an auditory specialist but oh thank you
again Niko can you sing us a song Oh God
nobody wants to hear that Tom might
though he he'll bust out in a song he
doesn't really good I have to tell you
he has a really good Roy Orbison
impression every now and then he would
like when we were kind of drunken
driving home from the club sometimes he
would sing some Roy Orbison and he said
it's just like but yeah so uh anyway so
anyway where was I so yes so since this
sound is seasonal as I said it could be
environmental in the sense that like I
said I'm not an audio specialist but
because when water is warmer I guess
the noise travels farther than when the
water is colder so I guess in pretty
like in spring and autumn when the water
is possibly warmer like it can go
farther and they can record it more
easily or whatever that's at least what
I understood so they think that this
particular sound the upsweep they think
it's somewhere between 54 degrees south
and 140 40 degrees west and they think
maybe maybe it has something to do with
like some seismic activity like some
underwater volcanoes or something like
that but they don't really know where
the origin is although they've they
first recorded a 91 and since then the
sound has been declining every year
since then so it does seem like it could
be like they still hear it but it's not
as pronounced as it used to be so it's
probably something in the natural
environment they're not entirely sure
what it is now there's another one of a
similar nature called the whistle and
this is a similar sound that was
recorded by various you know microphones
of the Noa is like a hydroponic array
and this kind of sounds similar again to
some kind of like underwater volcanoes
or something like that this is in the
Mariana volcanic arch of the Pacific
Ocean but this one was only recorded on
one particular hydrophone so they're not
really sure what what is that I brought
you some way for some German wavers
nopperz just in case an average mattress
only an hour's canopic can operas these
things are so good they are very good
yeah waiver could so do you want to talk
about the blue all I'm eating my cookies
or do I have to what's it
I don't romantic and you expect me to
mmm and you expect me to well as I said
well I mentioned the upsweep and you
know the whistle like earlier which were
other noises that were because like I
said the bloop isn't the only one anyway
is recorded like other unexplained
sounds they you know they think they
kind of know what's causing them but
they're not entirely sure so there's
like this big list that they have that
they you know haven't definitively
identified so the bloop was this very
low frequency sound that they detected
in 1997 was the first one now it it kind
of registered on a whole bunch of their
like hydrophonic array which like I said
was all these underwater microphones
that they had and a lot of their stuff
had to do with nuclear submarines well
that's why they initially put the
microphones down there they were trying
to like track the you know the movement
of like you know Soviet subs and things
like that like back in the Cold War but
as time went on they left them down
there for scientific purposes so they
every now and they record like some
weird sounds that they don't really know
what they are so some people have
thought because the bloop was such a
wide ranging sound I mean this thing
could be heard I mean sound travels
differently under was around basically
but you could hear it for like a really
long way away so some people thought
that look if this is and and the
frequency of it seemed to suggest a
natural origin they're not necessarily
saying that it was an animal but when
who's about it and I kind of remember
when this happened
when news about it first came out some
people were assuming because we're the
origin of the sound was thought to have
been was kind of near where HP Lovecraft
placed yes
underground like really or whatever it's
called ry whatever lah and uh where he
had that like in the Pacific Ocean so
some people said well it's Cthulhu yeah
because that's what it's that it sounded
like an organic No
it didn't sound like a man-made yeah I
heard I was I heard a recording of it of
the blues
yeah it's a weird it's a weird it's a
weird sound now the ones that they have
like if he's usually speed it up they
have to speed it up and like update
because otherwise the human ear would
not be able to hear it because it's like
outside of our human hearing range yeah
I think the actual recording is like
about an hour long and it just doesn't
sound last like an hour well it comes
and goes comes it goes yeah we have it
but usually when you hear it on the
internet you hear the sound in a few
seconds but actually it was like I I
thought it was an hour worth of sound to
compress maybe a few minutes couple
minutes huh it's weird it sounds like
some big-ass monster living on the
seafloor
but if there was a big-ass monster
living on the seafloor to be making that
noise all the time
regularly so it was so you would think
that so it was some kind of a rare event
I was thinking that maybe it was
something like a big ol ice shelf
breaking loose on that is the most
common explanation nowadays because they
do have some other noises that they are
pretty sure were like um you know ice
shelfs moving over land or like ice
shells breaking off and like in the
water like is like I said they have
these microphones pretty much everywhere
in this in the Pacific and so they have
recorded noises like this so the blue
even though it's not definitively you
know figured out what exactly caused it
that is kind of what they're leaning
toward because the frequency of it
because you know the way it kind of
presents itself is very similar to the
same sound that's like [ __ ] some
people were thinking it might have been
some kind of gas pocket being released
from the bottom of the ocean through the
cave or any I think I don't think so
because you'd hear it quite often I
think it'd be a regular sound it was
something that happened only once
recently and you'd have to match up the
time and the date when this sound
happened with some kind of satellite
photo to see if a crack appeared
somewhere on
ice shelf I think it was something big
whatever it was yeah in geological and
it wasn't repeated that was another
repeated and it hasn't been heard since
it was like a one-off or at least one
off in terms of a human lifetime or he
on human scales instead of like well the
thing it could have been something
geological today they thought that it
probably was they said that this is not
anything it's like it's not a bomb it's
not and they said doesn't look like a
volcano it doesn't look like anything
like that like I said you could hear it
for more than three thousand miles like
square miles like I'm gonna been a crack
in the crust of the earth that's like I
said they haven't proved it but that's
kind of what they're leaning toward
because it is you know that the
amplitude of it like the the way that it
looks like on the audiogram that is very
similar to other [ __ ] that they've
recorded that they know was like an ice
shelf moving across land or like an
iceberg breaking or something like that
and because it wasn't it's just that for
a long time they're like well this has
an organic source it's not like a bomb
it's not an earthquake it's not anything
like that so because it just happened
one time it was super loud and so a lot
of people kind of ran with it and we're
like oh was aliens or it was listed
gigantic like behemoths that like lives
under the ocean that we don't know about
and [ __ ] like that which I'm not saying
that there's no not some scary [ __ ] like
at the bottom of the ocean the because
I'm sure there probably is shouldna Zora
fine the thing is let me talk about the
ocean real quick the problem with the
very deep regions of the ocean as far as
we know there isn't any plant life there
like there's nothing really growing on
the bottom and for something to be very
large to be living deep down there has
to be like a really [ __ ] lush
ecosystem to keep it fed there is some
big [ __ ] down there oh yeah but it's
mostly things like giant squid and
they'll evidently latch on to stuff you
know fish maybe even whales I don't
think they eat whale I think whale eat
them
they found whale with a bunch of
although didn't they find that one it
was a whale or it was a gigantic shark
or something and didn't they find it
like washed up on a beach and it had
like big-ass I can bite taken out of it
on oh yeah
yeah Lake Hamm's alternate bass quit
that was like well it had to be like
some [ __ ] much huger animal whales
quit whale and squid fight each other
for some reason I think the whale are
eating the squid whale versus squid that
legs and then the squid fight back I
don't think a squid will go after world
maybe it will maybe a squid will go
after him no man take a bite out of it
you don't know how big it might be a
mutual thing where they eat each other
the problem with the region is very deep
down the bottom of the oceans if you
look at the bottom it looks like a
desert there's not much life there there
may be around the thermal vents but it's
pretty small for there 33 mph I oh yeah
- most of the [ __ ] most of the real
lush environments of the ocean around
like coral reefs it's a lot of life
there per square inch to the unit I mean
or per square meter a lot of life but
down in the depths as far as we know not
that much it looks like the like you
know you can look at a recording at the
bottom of the ocean really the surface
of an alien planet it's like the surface
of the desert right it's just sand I
mean like I said they do have some like
I said extremophiles that can live like
around thermal vents and you know that
live off chemicals that previously
nobody thought that anything could live
on you know so far most of it small yeah
there's a real like yes there's usually
a microscopic yeah so if it's so it's
living deep down it's not and it's big
it's not gonna get enough food that's
the problem would have to come up [ __ ]
has to come up where the food is and the
biggest thing we know over these whales
blue whale say okay which is the largest
animal to ever exist I know now that's a
big food source if you could eat it
alright but we've never seen anything
big enough to prey off those I'm
thinking that the whales are actually at
the top of the food chain can you
imagine if something I think that's
rather than a blue whale yeah like well
I think there was stuff in the past that
deal probably but I don't know if that's
like a Megalodon type of deal I don't
even know if the Megalodon was bigger
than a blue whale though and I guess and
I don't think I may
lived at the same time as a blue whale
no I think it's a lot of older well
because blue whale I made whales in
general that's like a leader because
from what I can remember and please
correct me if I'm wrong but I do feel
like there was there was a lineage that
kind of went on land for a little while
but then like went back into the ocean
you know I mean because blue whales are
descended from land animals not other
not fish it's a mammal it's a mammal so
they lived on land for a while but then
they I think the blue whale is the
biggest thing in the ocean I think it's
the well that they know of no yeah
honestly I think it's the biggest thing
to ever exist that they know of yeah and
which leads me to believe that that's
the top of the [ __ ] food chain in the
ocean we haven't seen anything preying
on blue whale or eating the whales
really if we did that'd be [ __ ] scary
because I didn't really like like
everyone else I had read how big a blue
whale was how big the [ __ ] was it's like
it's horrifying to like think about but
until you actually see it in person it
doesn't really make much of an
impression if you go to the Natural
History Museum in New York City they
have dwarfee of it yeah
they have a you know this thing on the
ceiling that is like a replica of a blue
whale that they cut and it wasn't even
the biggest blue whale to ever exist but
it was one that they caught oh thank you
again Nico damn thank you um and they
have it hanging up on the ceiling and
the first time I walked into that hall
and saw that [ __ ] up on the ceiling yeah
I was terrified I was like
intellectually I knew that they got that
big but until you see it until you see a
reproduction of it like with your own
eyes and understand how big that is it's
really it's really humbling imagine
imagine you're in the ocean at night in
a [ __ ] scuba suit and those things
come swimming by yeah that's right it's
like even just like smashing out of the
water it's like it's terrifying and it's
like I know they don't eat people it's
not like a great white shark or anything
like that but I might eat you
they probably
well my the thing about it though is
that a blue whale could probably just
eat you and not even notice because
you're just like a little like a little
chicken night blue whale eat plankton no
don't they do but I don't like I said
they could swallow you without noticing
burn whale don't though they have teeth
and you see uh Oh wheels up teeth yeah
but I don't think I think sperm whales
eat stuff though they don't eat they
don't feed on plankton do it oh I don't
know I don't think they do blue whales
fight on plankton most whales I think
like feed on like smaller like
microscopic and like you know they're
spooky whatever it is I mean and I still
have nightmares about like ocean type
thing they're big and there's a chance
there's a chance that that actually
could be have an intelligence similar to
a human intelligence they have a [ __ ]
big brain yeah whales are actually very
intelligent and like I said later in the
show I kind of want to talk about a
beluga whale that kind of talked like a
person oh and some other [ __ ] too
but yeah I've always found blue whales I
find them like fascinating but also kind
of horrifying because there's a sailor I
can tell you that tell you can squids
eat whales for sure yeah and like I said
I'm pretty sure I've seen whales like
watch too like dead whales washed up on
beaches that had like what looked like
squids I was never really on that I was
never really sure I mean people were
saying that they had sweaty squid marks
on but where they were the whales trying
to eat the squid and then the squids
were just fighting back although I find
the squid in the stomach and then or
could it be could it be that yeah a
squid will take a bite out if there's
big [ __ ] giant squid down there in
the bottom of that we shouldn't that
we've never seen before
no saying a squid might be able to take
a bite out of a whale and then run off I
mean a fish will try to do that to a
human trail like I was just gonna get a
little morsel yeah yeah I was snorkeling
in the Gulf of Aqaba in Egypt you know
[ __ ] the most beautiful [ __ ] water
you know you know you could ever imagine
me you can see the bottom 50 feet down
all right we're on those reefs and when
your back is turned his little fish
little sergeant-major fish will come and
try to take the [ __ ] bite out of you
yeah and then they run off like they got
away with so there's like look it's like
a big thing of me like yes
it's right turn around they run away
yeah yeah I don't have enough teeth to
take a bite off but they try well yeah
they try to get some like I said you're
in their little environment yeah in
their house you come in their house
their feed with your big medius yeah
they're [ __ ] feet and they're just
like hey like can I get a bite of that
there's some meat like swimming through
here maybe we should get a like a chunk
off that well I'm probably like every I
mean everything in the ocean they're
opportunists I mean like you would have
to be yeah this is why don't go in the
ocean because I don't want anybody like
taking chunks off of me
all right I'm not a barbecue so like I
said there have been some other
unrecorded you know like unexplained
sounds by the NOAA that are similar to
the bloob that don't for some reason
don't get as much traction in the media
I guess cuz bloop is such a talkative
name maybe that's what it is yeah would
that come out what year was that
97 I think first recording forever now
yeah well I remember when it came out
there was like some [ __ ] you see here on
art Bell yeah yeah art bells - is a
month like a sea monsters well because
initially they did say I think people
took the fact that they said that it was
organic
yeah and ran with it right and they were
thinking that it's like oh it's this big
gigantic like behemoth that lives under
the ocean and that you haven't
discovered yet which like I'm I'm not
saying that's not possible because the
ocean is rising and there's all kind of
like scary [ __ ] down there like a huge
flounder the size of a [ __ ] mountain
on the body I mean I don't know if there
is any reason to be I mean blue whales
are terrifying enough just the size of
them so I mean something that's larger
than that like you said something that
big can't really be a predator to the
extent that like say a great white as a
predator because you just wouldn't be
able to find enough food to sustain a
size like that you know no thank you
blue whales survive because they feed on
microscopic like little krill and stuff
like that that's plentiful it's like if
they had to live by E
people or seals or something I don't
think they would have attained that size
and/or they wouldn't have asked it as
long because you have to you know you
can't just consider the animal you have
to consider what their food service is
also of course that's a you know and
that's kind of one the reason why I
don't believe there's a Loch Ness
monster because there's nothing down
there what the [ __ ] would it eat yeah
something that size well they need to
eat a lot of rails are huge and they can
get enough food because they [ __ ]
travel a lot of distance there's a lot
of that taken plankton and stuff yeah
it's just a little small things and they
just eat all the time and they're just
like always vacuum cleaners yeah so you
can see why something that feeds that
way would be that large but something
that fed on you know larger fish or
larger animals would not be able to
sustain that kind of size I mean the
only reason that dinosaur was not that
big was just because one there was
plentiful food at the time but to the
atmosphere was different well I also had
a very high co2 content right and [ __ ]
lot of people are for the worried about
the co2 co2 carbon carbon dioxide is not
a poison carbon dioxide causes plants to
[ __ ] grow like crazy and greenhouse
effect would make a lot of [ __ ] lush
plantation everywhere which meant that
there'd be a lot of [ __ ] opportunity
for animals to eat and to give yeah
that's why dragonflies back then we're
like three feet we hear a lot of
propaganda about co2 co2 is not [ __ ]
poisonous carbon monoxide is poisonous
that's what comes out of a [ __ ]
tailpipe all right that'll kill you that
only comes out of tailpipes in volcanoes
so I see it if you were to increase the
co2 on the earth that actually would
become greener and more lush unless you
continued to increase it eventually
become like Venus so ya want that so
there's limits to everything I don't
like hot weather so I don't want it
would become tropical everywhere and in
the dinosaur age it was it was tropical
everywhere well yeah that's why
everything got bit and everything got
huge there's a lot of places it was big
giant the biomass explode the insects
were enormous yes and that the trees the
biomass increased a lot
can you imagine how big the roaches a
bit they were they were big they were
this I mean they were bigger than an
iron yeah they we're about that big
they're big enough they're sizable
horseshoe yeah and so there's a lot and
a lot to eat we're actually living in
the end times of the planets [ __ ]
evolution it's very meager the food
sources are meager today compared to
what they were people have [ __ ] crazy
standards they think that never mind
they think that's I think this is the
way the earth is supposed to be and that
the environments supposed to stay like
this well it sucks now this is this a
[ __ ] compared to the way it was 150
million years ago well it's a machine on
you a turbine well it depends on your
perspective if anything you're not if
you're not a giant a giant okay just
because it's for you because the
environment that you just because we
evolved to survive in this environment
from our point of view we think this is
the way it's supposed to be and it's now
well the thing is those are the answer
our to fix it - I wouldn't fix that let
it go
Oh No thank Fick that I'm just saying
make it more kind of conducive to her
survival I don't think that's the
problem I think that I think that
Earth's population is gonna decline
anyway well it may technology does not
require the population that you have now
people this is we're going in we're
heading to a post human world the only
reason why the population is the way it
is is because the Industrial Revolution
allowed a baby boom which allowed for a
large population and this was a this was
encouraged because the robber barons
that owned the world thought they needed
a bunch of people to work in their
factories so they allowed our ancestors
to be born but now that technology has
made us obsolete they will reduce our
population it's just like out of damn
it's just like out of [ __ ] Ridley
Scott's [ __ ] Prometheus yeah I mean
the [ __ ] the robber barons are
creating us kind of like the way
you would create androids where they're
workers but they don't need us anymore
so they're gonna erase us yeah as I
believe humans are yes they're gonna
erase this they don't need us anymore
that's what a lot of this is about
we're their versions of androids but why
make Androids when you just encouraged
the book the birth of people well it's
hard to make Android it's too hard to
make Android well they're gonna replace
us with androids eventually [ __ ] AI
[ __ ] superior androids because they
will behave and they don't need anything
say it's probably more more efficient
honestly it's eventually it'll be this
way eventually it'll be it'll just be
just like Zardoz you'll have a bunch of
[ __ ] hedonistic [ __ ] living
in a Salinas's where's our the giant
stone and as Sena stone heads out going
the penis is evil the gun is good and
giving a high scores to do to rape you
guys see and start us yes are it's gonna
be like that Zardoz what's happening now
man if they're bringing in Zardoz right
now I hope I have my [ __ ] little
g-string like Sean Connery yeah my Sean
Connery Easter and Sean Connery was a
night like that you know who an Oscar
winner did he wait wait did anyone ask
her I don't know but he must have its
own that same director did it Excalibur
which is a [ __ ] awesome movie
I [ __ ] love Excalibur I watched it a
little eggs our nose to start us I'm
gonna get is our guys it's the terrible
but in a really compelling way yeah I
mean the idea is rough so it's a very
prophetic move I don't know if I'd say
that but the idea behind it is so
ridiculous yeah that you can't help but
watch it because it's like thank you
again Nico that's right there you go
whatever I start talking crazy you give
me money man you're gonna keep me insane
bro see his his craziness and my
craziness and it's a money-making it's a
money baking minor premise usually you
should do your an offshoot show were you
just like Brandt yeah but what was I
saying
so and so anyway like I said you know
the bloop is not the only uh you know
noise like this that is
been recorded that they don't know how
to explain there was also one called
Julia which was very similar and they
recorded it in about the same area this
was a about 15 seconds long and they
could hear it over the entire equatorial
Pacific Ocean very similar and like I
said just like in the case of the bloop
they probably think this has something
to do with icebergs or some kind some
icebergs are cracked ice movie monsters
because they said that's kind of the
only thing it was something big yeah
they said it has to be organic
just like the the way that the audio
comes across there like it's not
anything man-made it's not bomb it's not
anything like that but they don't think
it's an animal just because it's way
louder than the loudest animal known
which is the blue whale which does have
a very loud call but they know what that
sounds like and they're like some sound
like this that can extend over 3,000
miles it had to be so they're like if
that's an animal that's a really really
big animal I think it has something to
do with plate tectonics yeah they're
like it so it probably is most likely
that it's something to do with ice show
eyes shelves moving ice sheets moving
like some kind of icebergs cracking or
something like that there was another
sound too called the slowdown which was
also recorded in 1987 kind of same area
where they recorded it all so probably a
large iceberg there was a another one
called the Train and that was also
recorded in 1997 and this one was also
just as in the other case is probably a
large iceberg because I like I said this
is the only thing that's gonna cause an
organic noise of that nature that's that
lapping of geologic scale yeah because
like I said if it's an animal then
they're like this is bigger than any
animal ever recorded because even as
wide-ranging and sound does travel
differently underwater it can travel
farther depending on what the
temperature of the water is and whatnot
but they're like if this had traveled
three over 3,000 miles underwater this
is got to be one like an animal way
bigger than a blue man blue whale which
is check in ancient times and people
would hear thunder and they thought it
was gods yeah
same thing I mean people pick up these
[ __ ] weird sounds learn at the ocean
I think it well it must be attributed to
something I mean like a big animal or
something
it's that same phenomena thing about it
so here's what ends up happening though
it's I feel like this is what ends up
having in a lot of situations and this
is I think this is more a problem of
science reporting rather than science
itself because I feel like you know
scientists will be like hey we recorded
this kind of weird noise like that we
recorded in the Pacific Ocean or
whatever it's a little bit unusual it
was much louder than normal or whatever
and then I feel like that when science
reporters report that to the public like
to the mainstream public they kind of
want to make it sound more mysterious
and Italy oh my god it must be like this
big [ __ ] gigantic animal it's the sea
monster it's this at the end there's
nice like but that's not always said we
just said we weren't entirely sure what
it was but it was similar to this that
the other thing it's like it's probably
an iceberg don't panic and then like the
you know the science media were just
kind of like no we want clicks so it's
like we wanted to be a sea monster we
want it to be mysterious and unusual and
I think in a lot of times it's probably
not you wanted a drink yeah sure hand me
that give me a garbage I'll throw the
garbage at
oh he's gonna even 3-under I can't
believe is normally two hours two hours
and the big show it is and we haven't
even like hardly talked about the
subject no that's okay nobody seems to
mind but like I said that's kind of
something I mean I'm I don't you guys
probably know but I'm kind of like a
science dork so it does kind of bother
me that I feel like a lot of scientific
kind of findings are sort of the way
that they're reflected in popular
culture and popular media is not really
exactly because everybody wants to make
everything seem more exciting or more
mysterious or more whatever than what it
is so I feel like they'll take a little
bit of something like scientists said
hey we recorded this weird sound and
we're not entirely sure what it is it's
like super loud and I feel like the
media will kind of take that and like
run with it and come up with all these
like unfounded sort of scenarios about
what it might be
and so I do feel like I don't think
that's entirely Sciences fault I think
that's thank you again Nico no I'm gonna
make Tom sing when it gets back when he
gets back but yeah I do feel like that
that's kind of and it might be a little
bit of the public's fault too because I
feel like they do kind of only want to
click on things that sound like quote
unquote Thank You Nico is paying for you
to sing I don't know if she wants me I
don't know she wants me to sing but I
don't want to sing I can't sing but I'm
like I'm not going to but yeah so I do
kind of feel like that's I mean and I
get that I get that people want mystery
they want you know something to be like
unexplained and [ __ ] like that it's like
I don't want to be one of those people
that's just like well actually it's this
that and the other thing but I do feel
like nine times out of ten there is
probably a mundane explanation just
because we don't know what it is yet
doesn't mean that we won't actually find
it so I don't think that I mean bloop
and Julia the Train like all the noises
that they've recorded just because they
don't immediately know what they are I
don't think that it means that they will
never explain it or that it's something
that we don't know what it is they're
just coming out saying like look we're
not entirely sure it does and it's
probably an iceberg because it's similar
to you know iceberg type noises we have
recorded in the past but you know we're
not sure so we're just saying that and I
do feel like any time there's any kind
of little gap in understanding or any
kind of gap in like you know maybe we
don't know what this is or you know
people will fill in those gaps with all
kind of crazy [ __ ] which is kind of a
shame but that's kind of like how human
brains work I guess which you know
that's been a constant source of
disappointment to me but like that
people will just fill [ __ ] in when they
don't have information so that's because
they like certainty they don't like
uncertainty so if you don't like if you
don't know what something is it's like
it's very human to want to like fill in
the gaps and like you know pretend you
know what it is or you know fill it in
with something that your preferred
whatever it is so
I do feel like even though a lot of this
[ __ ] like I find this kind of stuff
fascinating I don't think any of it is
alien intelligences or I don't think any
of it is necessarily and I mean we might
get into this a little bit when we talk
about the Havana syndrome I don't think
any of it is any kind of directed attack
or anything like that in some cases I do
think it just might be something
environmental
that's just like incidental to the
environment like there's just some noise
that happen in the environment and the
people just noticing it or it does some
kind of damage because certain
frequencies of sound can't do that can't
affect people's brains and I'm not
saying that but I'm just saying that
it's not all the time it's not
necessarily something that was done on
purpose and I do feel like people are
too quick to jump on to you know this
was done you know and like I said this
is why I'm not a big believer in
conspiracy theories because I do feel
like human brains are too engineered to
want to find an intent behind something
when there is not always an intent
behind something like sometimes it's
just [ __ ] that happened and people just
attributed meaning to it later on
because we're very good at doing that
and I'm not saying that there's not
meaning sometimes but a lot of times I
think there's not so as I said you know
with the bloop and all that kind of
stuff I do feel like that's probably
probably the most likely explanation is
icebergs you know I mean yeah like three
crashing and [ __ ] like that
so how you doing fine you sure yeah you
were in there a long time what what do
you think the bleep was
it's just bloop it's not the bleep ice I
think it's ice I mean I think the only
reason because like I said scientists
are very the thing about reality is that
it's all on a you know scale of gray so
it's like we don't want to necessarily
say this is what it is because I'm not
entirely sure even if they're 98 percent
sure that's what it is they don't want
to say that because well there's a 2%
possibility it could be something else
so
it's like we don't wanna you know what I
mean everything's like a probability so
I do feel like most of the time signage
to look we're 98 percent sure that
that's probably an iceberg but we don't
want a hundred percent say that shirt
but like I said since there that two
percent people are gonna run with that 2
percent school they're not 100% sure
that that's an iceberg so maybe it's
still aliens you know what I'm saying I
feel like that uncertainty but that's
the nature of science and that's kind of
the shitty thing is that people that
don't know a lot about science will take
that 2% and then just like run with that
[ __ ] and kind of crazy should to like
fill in to that but I do think I mean
it's still fascinating but I do think
that there's nothing I don't think it's
a sea monster but I do I do want to get
into like some whale show later on
because that's kind of fascinating to
you but I do want to say there's another
unexplained noise a rather kind of
similar to what do you what he's marking
- laughs and you trying to make me sing
a [ __ ] James Brown saw I thought I
said that you're I said that you were
gonna know James I said that you were
good at Roy Orbison remember I used to
sing yeah it's just thing Roy Orbison in
the car sometime a candy colored clown
they call the Sandman does he sprinkle
stopped us and he whispers go to sleep
everything will be all right I close my
eyes and drift away into the magic
analogous far as I remember you in
dreams I walk with you I can't do right
now that I can't do right I was gonna
ask you to sing them order I was gonna
ask you to sing crying but in Spanish
just like in Mulholland Drive
it was non Spanish no but in my Holland
driver was she did asset banish yeah I
didn't know that you never saw that
maybe no okay beyond that but you were
here so it's like that's why that's it
[Applause]
[Music]
like we come back for the club maybe a
little bit inebriated all right so uh
yeah what are we talking about Oh
somebody was talking about Pookie does
her own version of bloop banging the
window running on the head burn she does
we don't have a headboard but what she
does yeah one if she's out of treats she
gets mad about that so she bangs on the
blinds on the window next to Tom's head
also she will like I said we don't have
a headboard but she will jump up on she
always jumps up on the foot of the bed
for some reason she jumps on the foot
and then she runs all the way up and
then she steps across my eyeballs like
or across your stomach or across Tom
stones and should be and then she'll
jump down the other side and be like hey
my treat thing is empty yeah you might
want to look into that yes she beats me
up at night she does yeah she just runs
across me and next stomps this is for
real stomp but she well she knows that
your balls yes - Tom so my balls - yeah
yeah definitely she I think she thinks
it's funny it's ridiculous I mean she
like she doesn't do that she'll run
across my leg or across my stomach or
across my eyes yeah
like because she knows that that was you
yeah cuz usually I have like a blanket
and wise to keep light out of it but
she'll be like like right in my eyeballs
like at the pause yeah she's too cute to
get was just stomps on my nuts she knows
exactly so I mean she never like she
never runs across my crotch so she knows
that those are balls and then she's got
a [ __ ] cat she's smart
yeah she's smart well she knows exactly
how to target each one of us I mean
she's a part of it she did she looks she
well yeah I mean we figured that out
I've never had a cat as smart as that
yeah she's just like she's like a child
and how manipulative she is yeah it's a
true all right so
let's talk about another unexplained
sound now this one I had never heard of
actually but I just found this one all I
was like researching this is called the
forest groove sound now this was hat
this took place in Oregon forest Grove
Oregon this first started happening in
February 2016 now this has been
described from the people that have
heard it as a quote/unquote mechanical
scream so a bunch of people supposedly
heard this sound and somebody recorded a
video like where'd the sound was going
in the background and they posted it to
Facebook now other people that have
heard it said that it sounded like and
this is some of the descriptions of it
they said it either sounded like a giant
flute played off pitch car brakes or a
steam whistle or a bad one note violin
solo broadcast over a microphone with
nonstop feedback which seems a little
specific it's one note or it's a series
of notes evidently it's just like one
cuz I thought like I saw um like a news
report about it and they played a sound
I don't know who is the actual sound
that they recorded or if it was like an
approximation of somebody making a sound
that sounded like that but it was just
like this really loud like screech II
kind of yeah it was really annoying well
that's the sound of something rubbing
one thing rubbing against another that's
gonna tell me right now it's oh it's
some kind of like plate tectonics I
don't know it was I yeah I don't know
like it's hard for me to like imagine
because like I said I wasn't there so I
don't know how loud it was um so some
people said they heard it from like
tense like duration was like 10 seconds
at a time to like a several minutes at a
time like so this was reported like oh
say it out loud yeah for how far away I
don't know just this one town like
Forest Grove Oregon so they um they
pinpointed the noise to somewhere near
Gales Creek Road in this town in Oregon
now they did an investigation because a
lot of people reported this noise like
simultaneously apparently and like I
said described it in similar types of
ways but they weren't really able to
pinpoint
what it was or where it was coming from
there's no real Road in that area
I don't think so God means we'll make
noise like yeah they checked gas lines
um they checked like they did all kind
of like mapping and [ __ ] like where the
[ __ ] took place but they weren't really
sure but yeah like apparently like 200
people call them like reported this
noise people some people thought it was
like organic like maybe it was like
frogs or maybe it was like some people
sent of course said it was Bigfoot or
some people said it was aliens or no of
course it's not no so after a while it's
like the cops and everything like that
we're investigating but they couldn't
really find a source of it so they
basically just came out and said well
it's probably not harmful so just chill
out but we don't know what it is some
kind of machinery
well like I said a lot of instances of
the hum that occurred in different
cities were later found to be from
various machinery like you know ships
that came in a dock and like had a thing
on it that was making a noise or
something from a factory that they had
turned on temporarily that wasn't
normally on so I do feel like that's
probably the most you know the most
likely source was some kind of machinery
but they couldn't figure out where it
was coming from so that was another
weird thing might have been something
like a big-ass truck that had some kind
of problem like I don't know like a bad
differential or something
and when you were up near it it didn't
really sound that loud but it was the
right kind of pitch and frequency where
traveled real far yeah because it's an
odd I mean the thing about sound is that
a lot of people don't really think about
it but there is a whole thing where I
mean there's a whole kind of subset of
you know a perfect paranormal type of
you know investigation that says that
infrasound might be responsible for what
a lot of people are perceiving as ghosts
because infrasound in a certain
percentage of humans can cause nausea
unease a sense of being watched you know
kind of hallucinations
various other things so there have been
Kate like like documented cases like
that where there was some kind of
infrasound source in the area that was
causing people to see things or hear
things or show like that that weren't
there so it's weird how you don't really
sound is like something you don't really
think about but it can't actually
physically affect you yeah I mean
there's not enough information in this
case like how far was it her what was
the frequency what was the pitch what
did it actually sound like it might have
been like you said it might have been it
might have been something like a weird
truck that had a problem and a
differential or in the breaks or just
something crazy and it gave off a
certain kind of a sound that traveled
real far and only first a few minutes or
a few seconds and then it went oh you
know I mean whatever the surfaces were
that were rubbing against each other
evened out and then the [ __ ] changed
the pitch and it you could know that
here well couldn't hear cause I feel
like there are certain frequencies that
maybe could travel better in that in the
environment we're talking about it might
have been a real flat or maybe like in a
valley or something like that where
there was an acoustic effect there's a
lot of things it's like I said this is
something that a lot of people worry
about yeah there are so many variables
because it could be like all these
environmental variables that you know
normally that thing would be making a
sound and you wouldn't like notice it
would be a big deal but maybe something
else in the environment changed and that
made the sound more noticeable to you
like for some for whatever reason like
maybe it was like reflecting off of
something that wasn't winter more
nothing went to a museum one time to
have these two parabolic dishes facing
each other but there had a bit of
hundred meters apart and once you got up
on a platform if you started talking you
could hear the other people practically
on the only other one 100 meters away
it's just kind of a looking acoustic
effect that it's so where is perfect
transmission of perfect transmission of
sound across a huge distance I'd those
weird yellow so it might have been
something like that there's some kind of
weird effect it was just nothing but
just a real common machine a car yeah
and there was just like a perfect storm
storm allotted to factors that kind of
allowed it to light
amplify lion carry a certain frequency
out nobody heard it but it only lasted a
few seconds because the conditions
changed
something like that can we talk about it
didn't like Mythbusters didn't they
didn't they tackle the myth of the brown
note that particular Brown Oh dearest I
don't think it does well that the
frequency that supposedly will just like
make you uncontrollably you [ __ ]
yourself yeah um from what I could roast
a long time ago that I watched that
episode but from what I can remember no
one [ __ ] themselves um I don't know if
that and I'm not saying that sonic
weapons don't exist because they totally
do but I don't know the thing about
sonic weapons is that they don't really
affect everyone universally it's not
really you know what I'm saying
oh yeah they got some sonic weapons you
can put on the back of a Humvee you can
point it at a crowd and just scatter
them you could point it at a single
person and turn the power up so [ __ ]
bad and send you the convulsions and
kill you in that well in the sense that
what could it make everyone [ __ ]
themselves no no but they have they have
sonic weapons that can kill a human
you're no problem they've had it for a
while yeah I thought they and then but
what's what they found it was better
though and they had it in the [ __ ]
the second Iraq war they kind of kept it
quiet but they did experiment with it it
was a Humvee with a microwave weapon and
you could pull up to a building and
point that thing at a dam building and
bombard it with microwaves and [ __ ]
dudes and jump out the windows to their
deaths to get away from it that is
something that well in the queue like I
said when we kind of get into talking
about the Havana Syndrome some people
that like they don't know what caused
that but some people have speculate that
maybe it was some kind of might whether
it was on purpose or not they don't
really know but they just say it was
some kind of microwave frequency because
it was causing similar types of symptoms
to what you would see in like a
microwave type of attack you know I mean
mark away a weapon was supposed to be a
substitute for the fine thrower that's
how it started back in the 50s fifties
and sixties the reason like a cyclo
magnetron to [ __ ] make started with
the Japanese did you
these were working on a damn microwave
weapon in World War two we had our a
bomb project and they had their death or
a project which was microwaves but it
was kind of unwieldly I mean you'd need
a bunch of nuclear reactors so you'd
have to surround the damn island to
Japan with all these microwave with
knitter's they were planning on bombard
and ships with it you know incoming
ships and planes and if you ever seen
any of them damn Godzilla movies where
tanks were all up and shoot at Godzilla
and then there's another tank that rolls
up and shoots like lightning bolts at
Godzilla and [ __ ] and [ __ ] kills it
that's what they're talking about yeah
the microwave weapon that they were
working on a world war 2 but we took all
that we decided we thought that that
might make a good replacement for the
flamethrower but it didn't work too well
because you could bombard a [ __ ]
hallway or something with microwaves and
most of the bounce back at yet if I can
ring your bell you know it wasn't very
controllable yeah I can then decided to
[ __ ] with the advent of computers and
everything and a better power sources
maybe could put one on the back of a
Humvee and use it as like a non-lethal
weapon [ __ ] smoke people out of
[ __ ] holes and get them out of
buildings well you could [ __ ] put
them pump the juice up real intense and
[ __ ] get people to just jump to their
deaths to get away from this [ __ ] this
microwave is bouncing around inside that
building they played with it for a
little while and the beginnings of the
first Iraq war but then they it looked
bad you know I mean it looked bad to see
people jump to their deaths like that
well yeah it was kind of like bad PR so
they stopped doing that they kind of
kept that quiet but I know that it
happened well you know I use didn't
finally shave it well and and honestly I
think there was wasn't there in
microwave attack on an embassy in Moscow
yeah your trunk [ __ ] could drive some
dude crazy but they used the microwave
weapons in Fallujah they just kept it
quiet that's what I'm saying but but I
can see why that wouldn't be like good
you know public relations no people just
like jumping in don't ya even if you
don't like those people particularly
that's nobody wants to fight well starts
falling into the same category is [ __ ]
using poison gas and nuclear weapons on
people yeah so like a shitty of those
people are it's like you don't
necessarily want to [ __ ] see that they
just thought it would be bad public
relations it didn't look good it didn't
look too good on film video so they
stopped doing it and I guess they
probably thought that maybe it'd be
possible for an enemy to weaponize it
and use it against you eventually so it
might be better to nip it in the bud and
kind of like not do it so if somebody
else did it you could say hey don't you
just microwaves on earth we will we will
use nuclear weapons against you if you
do that so because we've been doing that
forever we told Saddam says do not use
do not use a [ __ ] biological or
chemical weapons on us if you do will
respond with nuclear so they didn't do
it yeah well and the thing about things
that you do well the thing about audio
weapons is that they're very low-tech I
mean from a you know from a
technological standpoint it's like you
know pretty much anybody can figure out
how to do that well sound you can sound
is easier to defend sound and microwaves
are two different the trail microwaves a
lot worse
but even though sound I think even with
ear plugs in your ears it still effects
yeah yeah frequencies that they were
using we're still enough to kill you it
[ __ ] high power and they've been
working on this [ __ ] going back to the
60s this isn't new technology no of
course not the Soviets in the 50s were
working on a radio wave weapon and
supposedly they were able to kill a goat
at about a mile away with a radio wave
and that they were doing that in the
early sixties so there's no telling how
far that went all that [ __ ] went black
yeah but you know yeah there's a lot of
weird ways to kill people well it's
weird because it's like you don't it's
it's not something that you would
normally think about as like something
that would be like hey let's employ this
as a weapon to kill people but
you totally can use sound a quote
unquote to kelpy yeah sound microwaves
and even [ __ ] radar what's another
way you can do and you can use and it's
like completely you know you can't see
it you can't hear it you can't you know
and totally deniable often radio waves
and you can use infrared IR laser to
[ __ ] burn people's eyes out and it's
invisible but that's banned yeah that's
what to do that yeah cuz we have the
ability to do that imagine it you're
sitting there you don't think anything's
wrong and all of a sudden you go blood
it's because somebody about a mile away
was using the laser emitter to burn your
eyes out with IR laser infrared you know
what if it was me just in the computer
it's like can't figures we were used in
IR laser to designate targets alright
for a laser-guided bomb they found out
that if you could you could point that
at a person and blind him special forces
was doing it they decided they were
gonna do that anymore that's good
because you can't control it they can do
it against you so what you do is you say
look we're not gonna do this if you do
it we're gonna use nuclear weapon on
ously wouldn't the world be a better
place if everybody felt like that looks
like well let's not do this cuz somebody
could use this against us they do think
that way the military's think that way
we had all kinds of agreements with the
Soviet bloc during the time I was in oh
that was a good thing about when I grew
up we were fighting the Soviets the
[ __ ] Russians okay and the good thing
about the Russians is that they were
just like us they were just well they
didn't want Harry being there there was
kind of like well we don't want to let
this loose cuz cuz then we'll go that
against Ernest and then there's not and
they were very professional and very
mutually assured destruction they were
very professional and they were very
very predictable very you know so they
were easy I just feel like if more
people thought looks like what I want
this used against my family and children
that was a good old days man it's like
if I would not want these used against
my family and children like imagine your
wife and children or your husband and
children or whatever like um you know
subjected to that would you want to
watch them too
ejected to that and the so vo then don't
do that in the Soviet Union fell in the
[ __ ] weirdest thing all of a sudden
we started seeing all the Soviet
equipment in [ __ ] Russian dudes
showing up before Campbell because we
were working with him well yeah they're
just like us they were for China
everyone's people right yeah they
weren't everyone's we were helping them
secure from this nuclear [ __ ] that was
looking you know no man and that kind of
killed me in the eighties because for a
while I felt like the propaganda in the
80s was that the Russians were like a
different species it almost seemed like
they were trying to like well maybe back
there it is it's like that now they're
trying to bring that back with all this
[ __ ] that they're involved in our
elections but you're not evolving our
elections name or anybody else's well no
I mean just people are people it's like
people are kind of the same everywhere
yeah so I you know just actually know
the Russ stop like the other ring
because you'd like it anything that you
can think of to do it's like other
people are thinking of to do all
Russians are different though Russians
are actually more reasonable than the
average [ __ ] people you have to deal
with they were very reasonable well I
don't care any people in general will go
try to deal with Middle Eastern armies
or like I don't find any people
reasonable I don't I don't talk about
just talking about organizations and the
organizations that we dealt with when I
was in the service there's there the the
Russians were easy to deal with it's
very predictable but that's good it's
like at least you know like what you're
getting into it was like you're dealing
with the first world country I mean if
they said they were gonna do something
mostly they were going to only thing you
had to worry about was like some of
their intelligence agencies well he says
he's always [ __ ] they're always gonna be
always [ __ ] around tips that's kind of
like what their job description I can't
talk anymore about this time you're
gonna get murdered
no okay he's clean as molasses yeah do
you want to talk about the mood is
noises do you know anything about that
what the mood is noises yeah yeah okay
so
these are again some unexplained noises
these have been heard in Buddhist
Connecticut probably one of the most
famous because I had never heard of this
setting before either but probably one
of the most famous things that Buddhist
Connecticut is known for so these noises
can be heard from Cave Hill located next
to mount Tom
I got many mountains they they named a
mountain after Connecticut now
apparently the thing about this that the
thing about the muda snows is though is
that apparently this [ __ ] has gone back
for like a really long time because
everything that I read about this [ __ ]
was like that Native American tribes
that have lived in this area for
thousands of years apparently there has
always been an association with this
area with like weird noises you know
what I mean so like they named the place
essentially the name that they gave it
was like Algonquin Indians like other
like Narragansett Indian stuff they
named it like something do it like place
of bad noises so this was like a
constant like source of like shitty
noises like coming from this particular
place nobody knows what's causing it
exactly although nowadays I think
scientists have come to the area and
they've kind of like you know looked
into it a little bit even though back in
the old days they kind of contributed to
it was like some weird like spirit not
necessarily an evil spirit but I think
like the Native Americans if the area
thought it was like because I feel like
Native Americans have this thing where
it's like it you know Christianity we
have that thing where it's like
everything's good or evil but you know
other religions have things for a more
gray area so they had things where this
was like a god that was kind of like
okay or not depending on what mood he
was in kind of like more like a Greek
mythology happening so they kind of had
that kind of thing going on but as far
as the scientists are concerned they
think that these noises which are have
been recorded it's not like imagination
or anything this might be coming from
like small micro earthquakes in the area
but that's pretty much the best they can
come up with they're not really sure if
that's what like I said these noise have
been going on for a very long time
because Native Americans all the tribes
in the area have like names for this
place and that's kind of one of the
things that you know is a hallmark of
this place is how like all these weird
noises come out of this particular place
and honestly this place in Connecticut I
think that's kind of the only thing that
they're known for yes these particular
Oasis and fun fact the muda snoozes
these are the basis for the noises that
were heard in HP Lovecraft's the Dunwich
horror that's where he got the idea from
so it's been going on a long time well
that's what I said well the Native
American tribes in the area yeah it's
been going back like those what does
this sound like yeah it's kind of like I
don't really know what it says it's like
kind of like a Thunder e rumbly gosh you
kind of noise but it's been going on for
like a really long time like this whole
this place is like known for these weird
like noises hmm I mean so many some with
plate tectonics an underground cave it
could be but like I said it's kind of
like well like I said the scientists
thought that my there's a microt over
every way but might be micro earthquakes
mica yeah maybe underground rivers yes
like that they say it's something
geological yeah is kind of what the
weird what what the you know you know
what I mean uh yeah so my Makka Moo
displays have bad noises that's what
they call it um so what are you looking
at what they're saying it's on my brush
and stuff
look I said rush is still trying to
rebuild the USSR says no the Russia is
not trying to rebuild the USSR they try
reclaim regain those old [ __ ] borders
and maybe like the power and prestige of
what the USSR was but they will never
revert back to a [ __ ] communist
economy that it didn't make any money I
don't know if you were around or not it
was just one big welfare state those
[ __ ] just didn't even have damn jeans
they were wearing tough skins okay
they're not going back to that time they
want a more
western-type what they want is they want
something kind of like the way the
United States was back in the 50s that's
what they want kind of like a
traditional western superpower they're
not gonna bring back communism they
don't like it oh good do you want to
talk about Wales
go ahead what's the next on the list
Wales our next home I was gonna talk
about this whale called no see do you
know about that way no no see it was a
beluga whale okay now he was initially
captured by Inuit hunters in 1977 it was
actually in captivity for 22 years until
he died in 1999 now the weird thing
about it is that prior to this there had
been some anecdotal evidence that beluga
whales in particular had vocalizations
that sounded almost like human talking
how'd that happen
um women now if you were underneath the
water and with just you underneath the
water with your natural ears this thing
sounded like it taught was talking kinda
okay well like I said there was still
there was rumors about it because some
like sailors would have been out like
Balu goes and they're like man we
sounded we heard something over there
that kind of sounded like kids yelling
or like people talking and we couldn't
quite tell what they were saying and
they don't wasn't in kept you really
know what there was but yeah but so they
had never recorded it prior to this time
all right
so in 1977 these intimate hunters
captured a beluga whale who was adorable
by the way there was video of him called
no sea and he was in captivity for 22
years
how big is a beluga whale they're not
gigantic they're like beluga whales
they're adorable they're they're the
like super white ones they look like
they look like a zero bar with bass
infants yeah you know what I mean
they're like super white right if
anybody knows for the zero bar yeah like
this [ __ ] bellows and well that's
what I said a zero Barna uno bar over
the uno bar mom just they have those
anyway they still zero as I saw one in
the store earlier today but you know
what I mean so the thing about beluga
whales like I said it was a kind of
thing where people kind of knew that
they could mimic human voices but they
weren't really they didn't have any life
work
evidence of it until an OC was caught
now he got caught in Manitoba and he
lived in captivity for 22 years he died
in 1999 sadly but they first noticed his
little voice in 1984 this was about a
four year period like after he became
sexually mature like his vocalizations
were not as human-like anymore but they
did kind of study him in this four year
period now prior to this beluga whales
had been called quote unquote the
Canaries of the sea because they could
mimic other species vocalizations
including humans so sometimes they had
noticed that scientists that were out
like studying other species or whatever
they would notice that like beluga
whales the noises of them like often the
distance would sound like little kids
yelling to one another like on a
playground or something and they thought
that was very weird but like I said they
hadn't really studied it to any great
extent now they did have a beluga whale
named Lugosi who was 15 years old in the
Vancouver Aquarium who reportedly was
able to mimic some human sounds and
could also say its own name which they
thought was interesting so that was kind
of the first one to be you know like
that was the first one that kind of like
throw a spotlight on it however no see
was the first one whose vocalizations
were recorded so they started recording
his vocalizations now if you want to go
on YouTube they do have some recordings
of it it doesn't sound like any words
exactly but it does sound like human
speech if it's like far away and you're
not like entirely sure what it's saying
you know I mean like the the cadence of
it is very human-like and the first time
I listened to it it was kind of it was a
little weird because it actually did
sound like a person talking it sounded
like a person talking like in the next
room or over like a like a McDonald's
Drive you learn this from people he was
no they just um they just sound that
like I said they're very like well like
um you know parents or something like
that that just mimics that sounds that
they hear apparently they can mimic
whatever sounds they hear in nature I
guess um and it could be that their
normal vocalizations are similar enough
to human sounds that when they hear
human sounds then they just start to
mimic them so they start to like record
this dudes and like I said there's a lot
of like [ __ ] on YouTube like if you
wanna listen to this you know this
[ __ ] whales it's a little freaky but
you know they first noticed it because
there was a diver and he was down in the
tank with the whale and he was swimming
around in there and he thought he heard
a human say out out out and he went up
to the surface and it's like who told me
to get out and it's like nobody told you
to out the whale told you to get out
yeah it sounded enough like a human that
he thought it was a human and he thought
someone was telling him to get out of
the tank but it wasn't it was the whale
it was the whale so I was like maybe the
owner if the will knew that that meant
out maybe he heard a human saying about
how either that like yeah that's what I
was thinking maybe the whale was like
get the [ __ ] and the thing about it is
that he he made like human vocalizations
but he doesn't make them exactly the
same way that a human makes them um he
makes them like because you know humans
kind of like you know talk through their
throats or whatever it's like the the
whale kind of makes them through their
nasal cavity it's real nasal and like it
does kind of sound like a very nasally
like but it still sounds like a human
but like talking through the nose that's
what it so some people have compared to
like a human talking through a kazoo
right not quite that extreme but it does
sound a little bit like that but that's
kind of why because they did put
pressure sensors and his nasal cavities
to kind of hear what hey people he's
walking she knows the door open she's
like yeah I'm here [ __ ]
but that's that's why it sounds like
that because they they produce the same
sounds but in a different way than a
human would produce them like we would
like come from down here but they come
from up here so that's kind of why but
like I said beluga whales and I don't
know if they've done any research on it
um you know sup
went to this you thought it's no life no
he died in 1999 he did he was in
captivity for 22 years it's kind of sad
it is very for it was I'm not really
sure it was in a research way they said
it was a nuit Hunter's captured it and I
don't know if they because I would have
thought that they were just gonna eat
him or whatever but they didn't for
whatever reason and then he ended up in
like scientific maybe the caption when
it was young or something he was young
yeah and then he ended up being in
captivity over 20 and then they ended up
studying but like I said they didn't
notice the human vocalization weird they
keep it just 19 they just in a research
facility like in a big tank and stuff
because I think once they realized that
he could make noises like a human could
make yeah which like I said had long
been rumored among beluga whales because
you know scientists had so when they
were studying other things Oh like a
there were these belugas over there and
it sounded like people talking and it
was a little freaky but no one had
really like recorded it or studied it up
to that time did he show any kind of
like intelligence well like your regular
intelligence yeah but just the fact that
they could like I said very much like a
parent or something like that they're
very good at mimicking other sounds in
their environment so it could be that
your boot you know Oh Pookie what's she
doin Sweeney oh she's like no oh no no
no she was like I don't want and yeah oh
there's pokey yeah at least she didn't
stick her button the camera no but yeah
so they did actually um so the thing
that he would do apparently was that he
would over inflate his vestibular sack
um which is the thing well that's the
thing that normally like it keeps the
water you don't know their lungs what
you're saying well yeah normally that's
it that's the thing that keeps the water
from good and then once right so he
would blow that up more than normal so
he could make that noise so it's like it
seemed like he was doing it deliberately
because I don't think that was anything
that he would normally do like in the
wild
so he was dead
do we have any other whales to hang out
with no I don't know he the like I said
it's like I did I've never heard of that
but he seems like quite famous it's
weird because it's his name is like NOC
like big letters and I thought it was
knock but no it's not it's no see
because I was reading a read an article
about him on Smithsonian and yeah they
were like no it's no see that's what the
anyway named him but yeah so he sound
freaky yeah it's freaky right yeah I
thought it was freaky I listen to I
gotta go here it's a it sounds like a
person but a person that is like talking
through a fast-food drive-through
speaker kind of okay like very but it
sounds like a person talking it's just
that you can't tell what they're saying
and that's really weird to think that
that's like a [ __ ] animal that's
doing true I'm so even nowadays like I'm
almost 50 years old and the fact that
like parrots and cockatoos and stuff
like that can mimic a person's voice
that's still for example somebody asking
if we're gonna publish are these shows
to Spotify probably one of these days or
anything about Spotify to you we
probably should I think they come up on
iTunes I thought or they're supposed to
be coming up on Isaac I'll go check that
shoot I don't think our stuffs going to
[ __ ] [ __ ] anymore
it's just if there's a very long lag
because what it does it's that it picks
up the ship from YouTube but it takes
like a while for it to catch up okay
because every time like I never checked
that [ __ ] because nobody comments or
anything like that so don't bother with
it right but um last time I checked it
just seemed like it was a week behind
all right okay and it just seemed to
like catch up because it does take the
stuff from YouTube and wherever I'll say
post it and then it updates on there but
it just takes forever what a three-hour
show well like I said you went on and on
oh he's blaming me blaming me it's
always okay so while we're talking about
whales alright let's talk about the 52
Hertz whale alright this story kind of
makes me sad actually
alright so this is um the 52 Hertz whale
yeah okay
so this is one sad little whale we don't
know who it is and the he puts out calls
they know it's a whale call they've
recorded it um but it's at a very weird
frequency for whales it's at 52 Hertz
now this is normally this is a much
higher frequency than other species of
whales which are recorded now
this whale it's weird because the
frequency of it falls somewhere between
a blue whale and a fin whale so they
think maybe either this whale may be
malformed or it may be a hybrid or some
people have suggested that the whale
might be deaf they're not really sure
but it's putting out a whale call at an
unprecedented frequency like there
aren't any other whales making a call at
this particular frequency so that is why
they call this the world's loneliest
whale this makes me so cess you guys is
apparently like made other people sad
too because like apparently like some
other people with like made movies and
short films and stuff about this poor
[ __ ] whale so 52 Hertz this is
according to Wikipedia this is a little
higher than the lowest note on the
double bass now as I said this is not a
blue whale call and it's not a fin whale
call it's somewhere like in between
those two things which is why some
people think this might be a hybrid
however because this is the only call of
its type that has ever been recorded
they think that this whale might be the
only one of its species and that it's
calling for mates and there's and there
aren't any which is why they call it the
rock slowly as well that's why is that
this is why it's the fat it's like a
[ __ ] sad story
so here did this start Tom it started in
as far as in the late 80s or the early
1990s and as well maybe alive since yes
since 1992 they said that the frequency
has actually like lowered a little bit
suggesting that the whale has matured so
they think that the whale is probably
healthy but they don't know if there are
any other of its type that it can breed
with which is you know because it's
putting out these calls and like no one
appears to be answering them right which
man that's this is so [ __ ] said yes so
if so they in it was a whale is
traveling alone yeah and it's seasonal
they said most of travel uh um do we
know that do you know they do well it
depends on the species I think some of
them do travel in pods but it's like
they do kind of put out calls like I
said they know all the whale calls it's
like the known species and they know
what they sound like and it's like and
this is the only one that is
transmitting at this particular
frequency and it is a whale it is they
know it's a whale because it's very
similar to other whale calls but it's
just unlike any other species of whales
it is seasonal just like a whale call
would be um they find it in the Pacific
Ocean every year from August to December
which is like the premium you know mail
Lanta
yeah when like the mating time mating
time and in after like the winter like
they don't hear it anymore so it's kind
of like it's going through its little
mating season and it's like calling it's
like hey ladies mates and like no one
responds and it's like that's very very
[ __ ] sad so they've they've tracked
it it's like the northernmost point is
like the Aleutian Islands of the Kodiak
Islands and it's gone as far south as
the California coast it swims like quite
a long distance each day like up to 70
kilometers and it's like calling during
this particular time but as far as they
know they have never had any other hmm
no answering calls and they're not they
haven't tried to find it well some
people have tried to find it but they've
never found this particular because
they're pretty sure this is just one
whale yeah so they think that if this is
one whale then like I said he's either a
hybrid because like I said a blue whale
in the fin whale he might be like a
hybrid of those two species or something
wrong with or he might be something
wrong with him
or he might be deaf or something like
that because the UM the researchers have
said that some deaf people have you know
contacted him and said you know maybe
the whale is deaf and he can't like hear
his own boat
and that might be why the you know one
of my frequency is off that makes sense
yeah that actually made a lot of sense
and I wish they had kind of gone were
into that possibility um but it's kind
of like it's really sad to me to think
that there since this little put this
poor little whale is like swimming
around he's like hey you don't know if
it's by itself or not it may not be by
itself but they don't hear anybody else
though I mean they have microphones all
over the Pacific like I said that's why
they heard the bloop that's why they
hear they're all that other stuff they
got that hydrophone array like all over
this all over that [ __ ] yes it was deaf
it wouldn't be able to hear anybody
else's call would it so it wouldn't it
wouldn't actually that would solve both
problems would it because that would not
only be like why it's frequency was off
with the other ones yeah
but also why maybe maybe if someone
answered maybe it couldn't hear it
couldn't move over here which would be
even more sad yeah so it just is just
making that call instinctive this is
bumming me out even worse yeah well it's
funny that they haven't tried to track
that whale down but I imagine it makes
the call and it moves on well they have
been trying to track it down but it's
like it's one whale and it's like it's a
gigantic ocean and it's like kind of
hard to like [ __ ] find pinpoint where
that sound came from right so they have
been actually looking for him but they
do have like the audio data from like
all those interesting to see what kind
of whale it is it's probably a deaf blue
whale it may be it may be and like you
said that would be even sadder because
like even if somebody answered like he
would hear it right and it's like oh
well you wouldn't know he wouldn't know
about whale Society so he wouldn't know
anything was off you just run around and
make that noise every now and then yeah
and you're pretty probably never seen
any of his own kind after so maybe he's
cool with being alone he's just kind of
like making that no no every whatever
might be crazy he's crazy as hell as far
as yeah mango badger says bloop could
have been the response yeah wouldn't
that be a plot twist
we were trying to answer you the whole
time yeah apparently there have been a
bunch of apparently a lot of people have
been had this has resonated with a lot
of people like a lot of artistic people
because they've made like some short
films about the [ __ ] there was a film
called the phantom 52 which is an
animated movie and this was kind of
about the this whole situation there was
another documentary called 52 the search
for the lonely as well which as far as I
know hasn't been finished yet although
it was the same guy that made a clabsi
which that was the document we saw that
documentary that's on Kickstarter and
there were like a couple of other like
mockumentary tech films or films where
they were kind of using the whale as
like a symbol for like loneliness or
trying to find love and I'm like an
unloving world and [ __ ] like that which
you know like I said I can kind of get
that because it is kind of a sad story
so let's talk about because this is
already been going on for three [ __ ]
hours let's finally get to talking about
the Havana Syndrome you want to talk
about Havana Center yeah do you know
anything about that nope okay so Havana
syndrome whether this is noise related
or not um
that seems to be one of the most
prevalent theories about what is causing
this but I'm not entirely sure that
that's what's causing internet so Havana
syndrome this is fairly recent this just
started coming out in like late 2016
this is something that has happened to
apparently only US and Canadian
diplomats in Havana Cuba and this only
started in August of 2017 now they all
started reporting very strange symptoms
in about this this time period yeah I
know this one and they're not really
sure see I thought that you know what
yeah I remember this so they all started
having these really weird symptoms that
were kind of consistent with honestly
most consistent with concussion yeah um
kind of a thing where they were having
headaches loss of memory um you know
just various things that have to do with
like brain injury and they weren't
really sure
what was causing it had someone at their
offices so for a long time so one of the
prevalent theories about this is that
and like I said no one is sure as to
what is causing this particular thing
and it's a very small sample size so
it's it's kind of hard to say but one of
the main the theories about what's
causing it is that it could be exposure
to pulsed radiofrequency of microwave
radiation yeah by the Frey effect which
is causing these types of because this
is as I said this is not an imagination
it's like some scientists have said oh
maybe it's like tinnitus or maybe it's
you know maybe it's a mass hysteria or
something like that
I feel like probably not in this
situation so like I said it's very small
sample size it's only about 20-25 people
but they do seem to have from MRI
results they do seem to have some
physical symptoms consistent with mild
concussions or something like so
something is causing this damage to
their brains and they're not entirely
sure what it is yeah I remember this so
as I said there was a microwave attack
that has been documented that was on the
US Embassy in Moscow so some people are
speculating that it could be that
someone no one knows who is targeting US
and Canadian ambassadors in Havana Cuba
although as I said that you know the
u.s. we have a little bit of a
contentious relationship with Cuba
candidate a little bit does not a lot
well connect Canada doesn't so much so
some people have kind of like pointed
out that maybe that's an argument
against it being like it's a good at
attack because Canada has a much
friendlier relationship with Cuba they
do not though because in in the
communist in the Marxist Cuban Communist
[ __ ] mentality Canada is just an
American puppet state that's how they're
gonna [ __ ] see that place although I
should say that Cuba did actually try to
they were actually pretty willing to
cooperate with an investigation on this
[ __ ] because like I said later on it
came out that a couple of ambassadors in
China also
came out with a similar I think it was
only two but they came out with two like
similar symptoms yeah so they're kind of
like thinking it's all the same thing
but as I said they're not entirely sure
what it is they don't know if it's
something that was on purpose or if it's
something like in the natural
environment that was affects you in a
particular way it is something because
they do find things like Intel it's
Intel the Intel community is different
than a normal [ __ ] government worker
they do illegal things and the rest of
the government doesn't know about it all
right I think in in this case what it is
you have it like a Cuban intelligence
agency using some kind of an old Soviet
radio wave weapon or microwave weapon
they're bombard and the damn embassy
with it and it's only a couple of Cuban
guys yeah I mean nobody else really
knows about it it's foreign ear bit well
here's the thing it's gotta be
small-scale because it's only a couple
guys like I said it's only I believe the
maximum is 20 for people that have
reported symptoms um so nobody in the
neighborhood around where the Ambassador
liked the embassy staff lives has
reported anything nobody you know nobody
living in that neighbor has reported
anything unusual so if it is this
direction it has to be very targeted in
the sense that it has to be like in
their homes or in because the one center
of reported sounds because some of them
did report like a metal like scraping
sound or sound like that which other
people around them did not hear they did
that it would have to be in their homes
or in like hotels they were saying it
because nobody else heard it from what I
read will remember reading about this
kind of weapon it's usually just an
antenna on a rooftop and it's
directional you can point it directly at
a specific window and bombard that room
with it with that radiation and it [ __ ]
with the human mind but it takes time
it's a prolonged exposure and the idea
was the Russians were working with this
stuff first this is like back in the 50s
had to do with their energy weapons
program Mike
wave weapons radio wave weapons the idea
was they were gonna try to change the
mindset of the opponent and kind of like
weaken them so they agree to certain
things when they're in a [ __ ] during
a negotiation that was the original idea
you know I mean it was a mind-control
weapon is what they envisioned it as I
don't think it worked though I think it
just [ __ ] your brain up and gave you
cancer get [ __ ] up your brain the
thing about it is that it probably
something like that is it's not specific
enough yeah I just think that probably
what happened is during the Cold War you
know the Russians were helping the
Cubans and they probably gave the Cubans
this technology which a lot of people
like in the 50s but the weird thing
about it though is that other people
that were in the homes or in the hotels
so these people didn't hear the noises
or didn't know it's not a noise we did
see well no some of a lot of them that
were affected did report a noise they
said it was a grating noise or that it
sounded like you were in a car with the
window open willfully it was it yeah
right but other people in the same
environment did not you know that checks
out I'm just saying that it's a
direction airy wave when it hits you you
might hear that sound but that's just
your [ __ ] brain Friant basically yeah
I mean nobody else here is it's just you
you're in this room that's being
bombarded by this stuff and you're gonna
have all kinds of weird sensory
anomalies I've heard some stuff that I
remember the feelings of being in
underwater
feelings of being paranoid feelings of
being watched well like I said that
could be Empress ound yeah well it just
it happened and what didn't just happen
in Cuba it happened in a lot of
embassies and they were targeted and
ambassadors mostly and it was done from
the outside in one case that I remember
reading about the building across the
street from that from the embassy was
being rented by the KGB and they had an
antenna sticking out on the star at the
top of it Anna pointed directly at the
damn ambassador's office and they just
kept that thing
and bombarding him and it was because
they were trying to weaken him because
there was some kind of an upcoming
negotiation in the UN and they were
trying to make him agree to something
that they wanted to happen you know I
mean months in the future and evidently
didn't work but he got sick well I
didn't that's the thing about these kind
of weapons is that they seem to me it's
like I'm not saying that they don't do
that [ __ ] but I'm just saying it's not
super effective because all you're gonna
do is just make somebody feel like crap
you're not like gonna make somebody
think what you want them to think just
because you make them feel like crap
it's like I'm not gonna change my whole
belief system just because you I'm just
like oh well I feel like crap that's not
gonna change my belief system based on
this is all memory you know I'm gonna
read about this back in the [ __ ] late
80s but based on memory the idea was is
to make a person suggestible but that's
not exactly what happened what happened
yeah the guy just felt very sick that's
what I'm saying and I feel like that was
maybe if this was a targeted attacked
which I'm not entirely sure that it was
but if it was all they succeeded in
doing was making twenty odd people feel
like crap and then just leave Cuba
because they're like [ __ ] this [ __ ] I'll
feel good another case to come and then
it didn't change their mind about
another case that came to mind is they
used some kind of a energy weapon to
bombard a political opponent and I think
it might have been an ambassador
they made him quit resign his posts by
Bob Barden and with that for mental
health reasons but it wasn't specified
from when I remember he didn't but who
knows you know I mean he resigned
because he felt he wasn't feeling well
well that's what I mean it's like and in
the thing about that kind of [ __ ] is
fifties [ __ ] technologies that's what
I mean it's like the thing about that
kind of [ __ ] is that
one it's not completely directed because
just making somebody feel like [ __ ]
isn't going to make them change their
entire belief system and so that's not
super effective I mean even if you're
doing that on purpose it's not a super
effective weapon
protip but
you know the thing about it too is that
there are so many other environmental
factors because when you're talking
about Havana syndrome which like I said
it seems like a real thing because they
did find some physical evidence of it in
the sense that they took some MRIs of
like some of these ambassadors that were
extracted from Havana and they did
actually do MRIs on them and it did look
like they have minor concussion type of
or you know activity that looked like
similar to what a concussion would look
like but they're not entirely sure it's
like they're not entirely sure whether
this was directed or whether it was
something in the environment because
they're like look it could be because
other people in the neighborhood did not
seem to be affected so it could be
something natural there like it could be
something in the environment such as
like there are particular calls of like
particular crickets that are at this
particular frequency that would maybe
mess up your brain if you were like
listening to it at a particular you know
frequency so there was that there was
like some machinery so it's like we
can't definitively say whether it was a
targeted attack or not if it was it
wasn't super effective because as I said
it they're not super sure and like it
didn't change anyone's mind so I don't
really know what mangoes for the same
him nom-nom-nom well they weren't trying
to give it to change their mind in the
way you're thinking they were just
trying to get somebody to [ __ ]
capitulate and [ __ ] you failed during
the negotiations right but it didn't
work the way they thought it would but
you know that's the thing about this
kind of [ __ ] though it's it if no I I
feel like okay now I feel like if you
are in a in an intelligence capacity I
would feel like you have enough
knowledge to pinpoint [ __ ] you on a
pinpoint and be able to like get the
result you want to get it's like this
kind of scattershot i'm gonna like
randomly target a you know 20 on people
with this sound weapon that may or may
not do what I wanted to do might just
make people throw up my
get people headaches or nosebleeds I
don't know what it's gonna it just seems
very it seems like there's too much
margin for error or at for intelligence
community [ __ ]
I feel like intelligence community
should have more know-how than just
doing this kind of generalized I'm just
gonna make people feel like crap and how
that goes my way not back in those days
this was recent though yeah I mean
Havana syndrome that Cuba that's to them
something is that Cuba's in the past I
mean they're still running cars from the
nature but and their thinking is is
[ __ ] let's just hurt them it's not a
sophisticated it's just not a
sophisticated that other people in the
area didn't didn't report anything no
it's directional this is microwave way
it's like a ray like a laser beam and
what they do is they would just point it
directly at a window in a building and
bombard that area that's how they did it
and they left it on so whenever you went
to work cuz it didn't require it didn't
take that much power when you went to
work every time he would work you fell
sick and was kind of a cumulative ya
know dime in it was like being in a
[ __ ] wave of infrasound or something
when you were when you were working you
[ __ ] your brain microwave yeah they just
left it on [ __ ] ran on probably [ __ ]
110 volt so it didn't matter they didn't
care if it didn't work it was just a way
of [ __ ] pestering the enemy that
that's what they used it for um the
Canada I can uh Cuba probably would have
some old Soviet [ __ ] like that laying
around
yeah because it didn't cost anything to
run it there yeah 20 of them gringos
yeah that's that's exactly that's all
your replays so too much well no I'm not
reading into it I'm just like saying
that there's a lot of things yeah could
be any way and because the sample size
is so small it's hard to know somebody
asked me about [ __ ] Canada did you
ask the Canada to work together in the
90s when I was in Canada was almost
considered to be kind of like America's
National Forest during those times we
equipped their arms they their their
equipment mostly came from us the
training was very integrated the like I
said they we the US Army considered
Canada to be our national
forest aboard that anything else yeah
they're an independent country but yeah
they're geographically very large
there's cities there and there's people
but militarily they were [ __ ] very
small and we were pretty integrated with
the intelligence agencies I mean CIA was
doing a weird [ __ ] in hospitals down
there
Britain [ __ ] remember the mind wiping
[ __ ] program that we talked about
from MKULTRA that was happening in
Canada so there was in in that era
Canada you know way it was kind of like
a protectorate that'd be a good way to
put it now is it like that now I don't
think so i don't think it's like there
now i don't think that but it was back
then
um if anything europe and canada are
trying to merger the one world
government which everybody know
everybody who's paying attention knows
what that's all about and you know
they're trying to get united states to
merge with it too which i don't think is
gonna work out but that's for the show
um
if anything else what are you doing i'm
see if there's any other questions all
right well I'm going to the bathroom
okay go ahead go the restroom is spooky
behind me no I'll be back I thought I
heard her yelling yeah she's down here
putting : where'd she go yeah she she
word what's coming up next that was the
last thing okay so which he comes back
we'll just go ahead and we'll go ahead
and [ __ ] shut the show down so what
you guys doing okay all right man it was
a three-hour show
somebody said we have naval ships from
World War two it must be somebody from
Canada saying that
yeah Casino Royale that's a good one
mana that's one of my favorite James
Bond movies all the James Bond movies
are good all the way up until Spectre
they're working on they had they have
one new one but they haven't released it
yet I think it's not gonna be that good
the age of good movies I think it's gone
Hollywood [ __ ] at least American
movies Hollywood movies that shit's
[ __ ] that's a wrap
they're done it's gonna be nothing but
indie flix and foreign flicks Hollywood
kept [ __ ] up they don't know how to
make a movie they just want to [ __ ]
their movies they just want to [ __ ]
show some political idea down your
throat they don't wanna tell you a good
story anymore how about moves Hollywood
they don't really want to tell good
stories anymore well they do but only to
the extent that it makes a [ __ ] ton of
money yeah which you know sometimes that
works out sometimes not so much but
that's how it's always been and today is
not a new thing no it's been sucking for
a long time we're sucked there's just
there's too much suckage in a row it's
been going on for about three years of
suckage I don't know I do I've seen a
lot of good movies in the last three
years so I don't really focus I don't
like yeah but that was like maybe
[ __ ] five percent of the movies yeah
but I've always been more into indie
movies really no no no I didn't count
the indie movies to the any bubo good
I'm talking out the [ __ ] big
Hollywood movies they haven't been good
they've always sucked up they've always
pretty much suck they both sucked I mean
the only thing that would not only think
from a big Hollywood movie that could
come close to being good with some of
the [ __ ] Marvel movies but man sort
of few them those last few Marvel movies
[ __ ] sucked
they sucked well they thought they just
weren't very they weren't they were good
they just hold it forgettable memorable
total but if you're into that like I'm
not really the best audience for that
because I'm not super into Marvel movies
I've only seen like probably like a
third of them the best recent Marvel
movie I saw was them I like them
well it focus on the villain and the
villains are always more interesting and
Farah superhero movies go alive Shazam
yeah and that was DC it was DC and
[ __ ] the Joker the Joker was afoot
Joker Joker Joker was a masterpiece and
I would say that [ __ ] Aquaman wasn't
that bad it was pretty good it was very
campy but it was it was fun though it
knew what it was
Bert birds-of-prey was I liked
birds-of-prey more than I expected to
initially it because I think I heard
everyone whining about it and I was like
I expected it to be bad but it was
actually [ __ ] good there's just a
regular movie it was a regular that's
not like it it's almost kind like a 90s
throwback movie that's what I mean I
feel like the problem is that one people
develop opinions about movies before
they see them and there's this whole
industry of particularly YouTube videos
that they want to like let's analyze the
trailer let's do this then the other
before the movie even comes out and then
so a lot of times I'm already like
soured on the movie but then when I see
the movie I'm just like oh it was that
pretty good and it's like I don't know
whatever was whining about there's
nothing wrong with it
they weren't whining about it um yeah
they were whining no no I kept up with
that okay yeah what they want about what
they wanted about what they whined about
was truth the main thing is is that it
had a shitty [ __ ] advertising
campaign well piss-poor advertise yeah
but that happens what they they don't
know what markets they didn't market it
the right way that's all and and that's
really what most of the whining was and
then the second part of it is that the
Harlequin costume wasn't cute she didn't
have a sexy outfit right but a character
always had that damn outfit right and
she did in the first one but the guys
cared and that was and that was very
much a guy movie that was a movie that
guys I liked it though girls liked it
but I'm saying that was the draw was
that that was a cute villain funny
villain movie and guys should have been
flocking to that movie and when they in
and
the advertising campaign turned guys off
and I want I liked the movie I just
didn't think first of all what's out
actresses name doing the one that from
Margot Robbie what's a Margot Robbie
yeah yeah she was from once upon a time
and house oh that's a fantastic actress
yeah well she wanted to make that movie
yeah cute as a [ __ ] bug and she
looked better in the [ __ ] first
outfit that they had remember when she
was in although I don't I don't know I
was more worried about the character
than the outfit yeah but okay you're
trying to overanalyze
look I'm not afraid of talking about
guys alright and yeah and guys are
stupid I guys guys you guys are very
visual it's just that that [ __ ]
original that original outfit that she
wore in [ __ ] what was named in the
movie uh Suicide Squad right that fit
that character and that was kind of more
like I did not see Suicide Squad like I
heard it was bad but I don't watch it so
I don't know if it was bad it did better
than [ __ ] birds of prey and I heard I
watch it I didn't watch it either and
I'm not making a judgment on the movie
it did better it did better the birds of
prey and from what I understand birds of
prey was actually a better movie than
Suicide Squad that was more fun I mean
from what I understood like I said I
haven't seen Suicide Squad so I'm not
making a judgment on that I haven't seen
it but you know like I said I do not
like make judgments about movies I
haven't seen because I feel like I don't
know but I did like birds of prey no no
I liked the action scenes remember what
the foot combined I like it better than
Suicide Squad I don't know because I
like the action sees I just didn't think
that her costume really fit that
character see I was like not worried
about that and I think if that costume
fit that character bed that movie was
sold and they had to focus they
advertising campaign [ __ ] blue well
like I said that seems to be a problem
and that's been a problem going back
goddamn it since I can remember because
I feel like there's a disconnect and
this has been going on like a since the
seventies at least probably earlier than
that there's a disconnect between the
people who make the movies like aka
they're artistic people and the
people are selling the movies aka the
businesspeople so you don't really get
and like I said I'm a graphic designer
I'm in an artistic field so I know that
there's a disconnect between the people
that actually actually create the [ __ ]
and the people that actually sell the
[ __ ] so it's like you don't really know
like they think they know what sells the
artistic people think they know what
looks good so there's always like a
disconnect between those two things and
I think that that is an eternal problem
in any kind of creative field
particularly Hollywood and I have seen
like [ __ ] man I've seen trailers from
like the 60s the 70s the 80s that the
trailer had nothing to do with the movie
or the trailer with shitty and the movie
was good or vice versa
so I feel like there's not the way they
trying to sell a movie is always it's
always different than like what the
movie is like I don't I don't think I've
seen there's very few trailers that I've
seen that were like that was when I saw
the movie I was like yeah that was
exactly what I was expecting I mean that
hardly ever happens what they do with
what they do with birds appraised they
came out and say they said [ __ ] this
movie's gonna make all you misogynist
[ __ ] men [ __ ] hate it this is a
girls movie and if there is what they
said and then they said this is stunning
and brave and you don't come see our
movie so they didn't but really when you
go to see the movie it was a regular 90s
throwback movie they've been making
movies like that since we were kids it
was well that's another thing it was
just the same old [ __ ] movie but it
was like oh my god my little man
feelings are gonna get hurt by this
movie and it's like the fact that they
wouldn't go see that movie that is like
the pussiest thing ever it's like this
was a totally normal movie it's like
please just go see the [ __ ] movie
it's like make up your yeah that's not
who seeing movies who seeing whose needs
are so [ __ ] fragile who's seeing
their friends you're reading into it the
dudes who are seeing these [ __ ]
superhero movies are [ __ ] sensitive
that way I'm not I don't give a [ __ ]
I had [ __ ] a list we would just go to
the movies just to go see a movie but
these guys who are watching these [ __ ]
movies you know man these ended all the
superheroes they took it personally and
that's who the movie was supposed to be
marketed towards so it's kind of like oh
no we're stepping on things she stepped
on movies are no longer for the general
audience anymore because the general
audience stays at home you know so
that's that's you is that I think
sometimes people fall for let's court
controversy to just know maybe yeah the
thing about it is that it usually works
because that's a piece that court
controversy made millions that's exactly
what I think so I I kind of feel like
exactly what that's why I don't really
care they tried it they tried to get
free advertising through the controversy
but it [ __ ] backfired I mean that's
how I say the kind of controversy just
you and I are some to me saying I don't
like follow it that so so it lik look if
someone is whining about it's all I care
about somebody whining about a movie I'm
just gonna go if I want to say hello
back although maybe look I I'm a
Salesman I'm an X salesman we'll go back
right to what I said before it's a [ __ ]
advertising campaign they should have
known better than to do that because
they didn't know the audience they're
very disconnected from the audience they
don't know they didn't really understand
geek culture that well they thought it
was something that it wasn't
you know so they I don't know it's
workday pass because riling up retards
and you know like all the whining people
about and you know they're hurting my
man feelings and [ __ ] like that it's
like that has worked in the past because
movies that they marketed like that have
made like millions billions of dollars
what so you know had me read Mad Max
fury road like and you know [ __ ]
Captain Marvel which everybody liked
[ __ ] much but made like billions of
dollars so even though it was like it
was an okay movie they were gonna seek
at Marvel anyway because I'm saying is
that half so it's like the fact that
they some like some people were like
whining about I don't think that applied
to fury road I don't think that applied
I remember a lot of people whining about
that [ __ ] though I remember a lot of
whining about this I don't know if you
know I remember a lot of whining about
that
I like your eye did you well everybody
like fearwood that was a [ __ ] awesome
movie but I remember a lot of whining
about it as well the thing is about your
did fury road - well at the box office I
think he did did it
I think he did very well yeah yeah and
like I said even different systems look
at several years on it cos they'll be
out like you know it's like the best
movie of the decade I wish I would not
aren't you got a look at you got a look
at the difference look at the difference
between fury road and [ __ ] birds are
for a prey well is just a standard it
was it wasn't like a masterpiece right
but it was an enjoyable move had a good
time watching it it was like there was
nothing in it that like pissed me off or
me in LA and it was a good movie it was
a good movie I'm okay so many people who
have come from a sales background maybe
you'll understand what I'm talking about
her know what I'm talking about with
sales and in every sales pitch there's a
diminishing return so I think what
happened is is that you could sell
things that way for a while but there
was diminishing returns they should have
known that that kind of technique was
getting old because they don't do it
anymore didn't do her stuff yeah like
like everything else just like
everything else advertising things go in
trend go in transit it's like for a
while something will work for a while
had they had they taken birds of prey
and sold as an old-fashioned throwback
90s movie it would have [ __ ] really
sold because really the tone to me
almost like on par in a way of like kind
of like the movies like The Crow and
[ __ ] like that it was like a 90s movie
didn't it did kind of like or terrible
yeah yeah just like that so there was
really nothing special about the movie
yeah it's like and it was a perfectly
fine inaudible 90s yeah movie it's like
it wasn't a masterpiece yeah like Mad
Max fury road was no it wasn't like but
it wasn't it was I had a good time with
my tank it was fun
more like it was a funny movie I
wouldn't mind seeing it again yeah um
but it wasn't you know it wasn't
anything I'd seek out but if somebody
had it on and I was like I would watch
it again it's like I'm just like
yeah so it's kind of like I don't know I
feel like people make too much out of
things and like I said before you know
being almost 50 myself it's like I can
remember all of the pissing and moaning
about movies and all the sequels and
blah blah blah about [ __ ] that happened
back in the 80s and people are still
going on about that nowadays like it's
that oh everything sequels it's like
everything with sequels back then - it's
like - you guys don't remember that [ __ ]
you not remember yeah everything was
like oh my god yeah yeah but it is time
for new properties it is but it's like
that's this has been going on for like
forever and I feel like people forget
that it's like now is like different
it's not different
no Mad Max movies for sequels actually
each one was it sprayed but that's not
exactly what I'm talking about I'm
mostly talking about like no people are
talking in there I'm listening to what
they're saying no none of these men none
of the Mad Max movies were direct sequel
well they're not technically sequels
because they're just like they're
they're just kind of like movie
sentencing you know I wouldn't really I
wouldn't really classify those as sequel
you're always being told a story by
somebody in a way except well maybe the
first one yeah but the feral kid is
narrating a story that he remembered and
then the [ __ ] in in the in in the in
in Thunderdome the girl is narrating a
story about Max and then you know the
girl who ran the little tribal kids and
then in fury road you're being narrated
a story by the [ __ ] historians what
were they the first time tellers or
whatever they were yeah what so these
are all stories out of a
post-apocalyptic Bible about Syme when I
like that concept better yeah I mean
it's it's a wider scope you can do more
with it it's like you don't have to do
like oh you know this happened in this
like a lot of slasher movies had it's
definitely mythology because right
because Mad Max has interceptors
destroyed in each one
basically oh yeah they're not her except
in [ __ ] Thunderdome I don't think his
interceptor appears I always accepted
that it wasn't necessarily happening at
the same time and or it wasn't
necessarily happening in reality yeah
yeah I I just always accepted it was
like a mythological your being
all that someone was told to you you're
being told a story about something to
have a long time ago which like I said
that's a that gives you a lot more
leeway leeway like as a writer because
it gives you a whole universe you can
expand it it's like you don't have to
worry about like you know being you know
exactly you know you don't have to like
you know adhere to the exact timeline or
the exact details of like the previous
stories like I said I was thinking more
of like like I said cuz I'm a horror
person it's like so I'm talking about
more about horror franchises where you
had you know the big ones that came out
in the 70s or 80s and then they had made
like 40 million sequels and that they
had to like continue with the timeline
and they had to get more and more
convoluted and ridiculous to like fit
[ __ ] into you you know look what
happened with the [ __ ] Halloween
franchise
we'll look what happened with the Friday
the 13th franchise look what happened
with the Nightmare on Elm Street
franchise for example and it's just like
you kind of see where I kind of see
where that idea came from of like oh
they're running out of ideas but I don't
know like I've always kind of been I
always take like a longer view because
there's always been bad [ __ ] and good
[ __ ] that comes out in every era there's
bad [ __ ] nowadays but there's a lot of
good [ __ ] nowadays too it's like you
can't just focus on bad [ __ ] all the
time
or you'll be one of those people that's
like oh well everything was better back
in the old days and you and I never
wanted to be a person like that and if
we wanted to feel like that old person
that was always like complaining about
how [ __ ] was like better back in the old
days and it's not like some [ __ ] was
better but some [ __ ] was not better yeah
and it's like there's always good [ __ ]
you can find nowadays it's like I don't
know why people are always like so
reluctant alright well thank thank you
guys for showing up this show it's about
time looks like a show suck a wine and
down it is oh my god we father's gone up
for four hours four hours in [ __ ]
people are getting antsy I think
probably we've only talked about the
topic for maybe a total of like 25
minutes no we didn't no I'm just saying
like on that days was the next time
we're streaming we are gonna stream
tomorrow or like I said we will probably
do
get a review remember that movie we
watched last night on shudder it's a new
shutter original yeah the beach house
yeah
environmental horror which is actually
quite good yes check it out so we'll
talk about that tomorrow and I want to
do a live stream on Monday because I
want to talk about [ __ ] dark because
I just watched all [ __ ] three seasons
that I still got two more okay
episodes season three and then I'll be
done and then I can catch up on the [ __ ]
cuz season three is the last one so we
can all talk about that everybody this
end of that [ __ ] so we'll talk about
that on Monday but other than that we'll
see you guys soon hopefully you guys
have enjoyed it remember like share
subscribe good or a patreon page go to
PayPal go you guys all know all that
stuff all you guys that are here so
we're gonna finish it up for what it
what days it's Saturday night yeah
hopefully you guys have a good rest of
your Saturday
thank you all for something bye thanks
for your contributions we will see you
again tomorrow for a movie review